hahaha
nobody's scared right
check check mic check
I mean last week somebody kind of
freaked out a little bit they didn't
think I would be here before
before the time started you know
I'm just sitting here watching you guys
chat
welcome welcome everybody welcome
all right so before we before we switch
scenes here
I must warn you all
not
to scream
okay
don't don't scream okay
all right are we ready are we ready
[Music]
how are you I know I know we have some
people who are
a little bit afraid of
[Music]
our arachnophobic friends here
don't scream it's it's okay
don't be afraid I've these this spider
it's it's in a it's in a good spot here
he assured me he's just gonna hang out
here
for the rest of the stream that's it
he's not gonna move he's he's right
there
he settled in
got the jack-o-lantern over here
borrowing this for my son
hahaha
okay that spider is okay with me nice
thought you meant don't scream because
of your face oh no no
like dude I put like a spider in a video
and people freak out they freak out
zutara babe zero nine thanks so much for
becoming a channel member and then Elwyn
right on the heels of that membership L
win gifting out five new memberships yet
again
Ellen just I mean
uh you're spoiling me Ellen you're
you're spoiling me welcome to Griffin
every week
elwyn's showing crazy support for the
stream Owen thank you so much those of
you who see your names popping up right
now
you just got a gifted membership from
Elwyn so make sure you thank them in the
chat
[Music]
let's see who all got one
who all got one Shadow guided did I see
shadow guy to just say
I think shadowguided lost their gifted
membership and might have just gotten
another one so Alicia Dustin extra IDK
and then I think I said Dustin right
some of them for some reason it repeated
some of them
but all five of you
just Elwyn DeGeneres indeed right thank
you so much Ellen very much appreciated
all right I mean it's it's it's
automatic L one just starting off the
Stream
in glorious fashion now if you guys are
wondering I saw some people uh before
asking about the music we are rocking
with a more Halloween Vibe tonight so it
is in the video description but then
here's a link to it in the chat as well
for anybody who's interested now
lowercase Logan
lower case Logan gifting five more
memberships
Logan thank you so much dude let's see
okay we've got star days trail with a
gifted membership
oh I can actually see all the well you
guys can see them too you can see them
in chat
Andrew Avery
the stream elements bot is actually
working tonight you know
I need to move it for this like for the
for the full cam view I don't know that
I like it popping up right here in my
face but wait did they just stop
I shouldn't have I shouldn't have
insulted them
I shouldn't have insulted them lowercase
Logan definitely gifted five but I think
oh I only saw so it should be stardase
Trail Jason Hodges Danielle Templar and
let's see is there one more that got
gifted
I think there was one more too Andrew
Avery
all five of you just got gifted
memberships not sure why they all didn't
pop up maybe it was because I insulted
the little on-screen element they got
upset and that was that so Dustin feel
like there aren't enough Hufflepuff
emojis
we I always feel like Gryffindor is
probably the the one that gets
and and that's my house I'm a Gryffindor
but I feel like that one rarely always
lots of slytherins lots of ravenclaws in
the chat
and then probably Hufflepuff and
Gryffindor somewhere thereafter
all right let's see what could we do for
tonight's poll
what could we do for tonight's poll
let's see here I'm gonna create a poll
right here
oh I got a good one
will we have more than
I'm trying to decide if I want to say
three or four companions I'm gonna say
four companions
will we have more than four companions
in
Hogwarts Legacy
yes no those are the only options we
need ask your community boom all right
there you go guys you can vote in the
poll
all right let me uh we we do have slow
mode on some people were asking about
that last time so slow mode
just to help me keep track of the chat
nothing more
that's it I fully confess so I think
it's on like a 60 second so not not too
short but if you guys are wondering why
you can't immediately type another
comment that's all it is so nothing
against anyone just trying to help me
keep better track of the chat because I
always like to start off the streams
by welcoming everyone everyone who has
said hello so I'm gonna scroll all the
way up to the top and do that now we
have both Logan's here again which made
lowercase Logan end up changing his name
now it decides
now it decides it's gonna work
okay we got Bradley there Bradley
congrats oh no wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
I think we just had it we just had five
more gifted
this time let's see who was it it was
Ravenclaw Tyrell gifting out five
memberships
welcome to Griffin that's 15 memberships
right at the start of the Stream
guys thank you so much
Natasha Ford getting one of the gifted
memberships so those of you getting the
gifted memberships now what does that
unlock well you get a discount on merch
like our order of Merlin shirt right
here
you get
the emotes in the chat you'll see the
little uh all these little emoji that
people are using like the Gryffindor the
Voldemort one Dobby laughing
all of those you get access to those now
you can use those anywhere on the
channel so if you're commenting on one
of my videos it doesn't have to be live
you can use them there too and of course
you can use it right here in the live
stream
so man thank you guys so much awesome
way to start the Stream
all right so we got Logan here wait
whoa whoa whoa wait
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
I'm just now seeing your comment Logan
oh my gosh so wait let me get this
straight we we now have three Logan's in
the chat which I mean Logan's
it's not like a super common name but
it's not a super rare name either but
still
we've got Logan Isom we've got Logan and
now we have a lowercase Logan and
apparently they were all three here
hanging out before the stream even
started
are you guys sure you're not making like
an ALT account or something is that
what's going on here
all the Logan's are welcome come one
come on we got three Logan's here
tonight pilot Joseph is here asgore bris
is here Draven Bender boy rocks
Professor Abbott welcome back Dylan
what's up Dylan Channel member Dylan and
also moderator of the stream here uh
Draven is here Lily Potter is here
Lily Potter oh my goodness
Elwyn of course Channel member as well
gifting out of membership nose of Sauron
is here once again as well we got stream
elements in the house Shadow guided who
Shadow guided yeah Shadow guided was the
one who said my membership expired and
then they just got gifted another one
Neil how's it going Neo welcome back
Moon Lily so we got Lily Potter and we
got Moon Lily
oh my gosh so many L's tonight the
lilies I saw Levi in here we've got
three Logans
ravenclawed Tyrell is here DJ and a
welcome back DJing Channel member uh
let's see nose of Sauron we saw we saw
Professor Abbott we saw uh Jake is back
as well Jake what's up Colonel Everett
both Jake and Colonel Everett channel
members as well soft-spoken one another
Channel member IDK I think IDK might
have gotten one of the gifted
memberships there Dustin we still have
four holidays before it comes out hey
it's it's going by a lot faster now I I
feel like now the time is just flying by
dude I I really do
I really do so many good games getting
ready to come out It's Just Gonna Fly by
Dr sherbet Channel member Neil Harrison
Channel member Patty Foote welcome
uh let's see Aaron Brewer another
Channel member on my way home from work
listening to this from my phone hey oh
that's awesome Aaron however you can
support just make sure you keep your
eyes on the road
keep your eyes on the road
Shadow guided let's see Nico hey another
Channel member and channel moderator
guys guys guys I Gotta Give a big big
shout out to Nico big shout out to Nico
who just basically single-handedly
revamped our Discord
we do have a Discord a lot of people ask
I don't talk about it a lot at least I
haven't I'm gonna talk about it a lot
more now because honestly I hadn't
really done much with it I hadn't had
the time to do much with it Nico my man
just got in there and has really
freshened up the place made a lot of new
see I don't even know what they're
called like subreddits channels
forums topic I don't know but he made a
lot of the a lot of the things
you can get sorted you could choose your
own house so he's probably already
posted the link in the chat because he
knows I'll fumble around to me trying to
find it so he probably already has it
and is posted in the chat if he has it
we'll get it for you here in a second
but check out the Discord guys it's uh
in the lead up to Hogwarts Legacy I I
think it's gonna get even more insane so
it'll be it'll be great once the game
launches uh I know there's a lot of good
Hogwarts Legacy communities out there so
I know expecto go has a really active
Discord
and I mean I didn't expect there goes
Discord so
um but yeah we really honestly
I hope that we can build something like
that I really do I love James and love
love the community he's built I know a
lot of you are we have a lot of overlap
in our community
so but thank you Nico seriously guys
seriously Nico has done a fantastic job
and it's just the beginning we want to
take your ideas so there's a suggestion
area over there in the Discord
so make sure you oh my gosh dude I
almost freaked out I almost freaked out
it was a I think it was a definitely my
wife's hair way too long to be mine but
I I feel thought it was a spider web
like wait what the heck
legit spider web in here what's going on
oh my gosh all right uh let's see Dr
sherbet Dustin lowercase Logan Alicia or
is it Alicia probably
see I always I've seen some people
pronounce that Alicia and some people
Alicia
so my apologies if I said well I I
definitely got it right one of the two
ways was correct so
Nightwing back in the house as well
uh let's see Katrina how's it going
Katrina Arcane Master 39 Dr Robo Panda
Channel member in the house
Olimar 92 a Olimar another Channel
member welcome back
sporting the Hufflepuff icon right there
oh there's Levi I knew I saw Levi in
here another Channel member
Diogo quilhaus evil poppy oh my gosh we
got to talk about poppy you guys we
gotta talk about poppy we we do
all right let's see we got Professor
Abbott there's Nico uh Christopher Brody
a welcome Christopher dude I love the
Harry Potter movies as well but not
nearly as much as I love the books
manav welcome enough
Darren how's it going Darren welcome to
the Stream
JP raven fire
oh yeah JP's the one who said I thought
I thought your face something was wrong
with your face
but what if I was just in like full-on
horror makeup or something
no I'm not I'm not a big like horror guy
like I have fun like Halloween's always
fun but more you know more of a
fun family friendly Halloween if you
will Professor Abbott in the house
how's it going Professor Abbott
all right seen a lot of the same names
now I think we're getting caught up
Andrew Avery if I didn't get you sorry
uh
welcome Andrew oh Andrew got one of the
gift it's nice nice nice
Professor Abbott Dr sherbet Templar
gaming careless streamer hey careless
dreamer welcome back another Channel
member here in the house dude like
I think it was Dylan or somebody was
joking last time about it's pretty much
going to be all channel members in here
that's the point we're getting to man
Katrina what's tonight's discussion well
I put out a poll on Twitter and I put
out a poll on
the YouTube Community page because I
said hey
there's there's been news since our last
live stream but I've I've posted videos
on it but there was no news Monday and
there was no news Tuesday today so I put
out a poll saying hey you guys want me
to live stream like God of War live
stream
um Spider-Man mods Morales or you want
me to just recap the Hogwarts news
because there's nothing new
other than some little teases I can draw
for you but there's nothing like majorly
new right so
but the poll was overwhelming I mean you
guys overwhelmingly said you want to
just hang out recap the news which is
cool with me it's cool with me I
definitely want to do more uh
Ravenclaw wait why is that just now
popping up or did Ravenclaw Tyrell he
gifted five more
oh my goodness Ravenclaw Tyrell thank
you so much
how are you that's welcome it's back to
back gifted memberships right there
all right if you see your name pop up
right here how are you you just got a
gifted membership
so there you go Katrina that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna recap the
latest news
how are you welcome all right we got
Shadow guided Nathan Channel member
welcome back Nathan Jason Hodges here in
the house as well Natasha Ford
J Rossi for real still hasn't got a
gifted you gotta be kidding me
maybe Jay Rossi maybe J Rossi is missing
the pop-up that says hey
accept the gifted J Ross is here every
stream
how's it going J Rossi welcome back
Hufflepuff
in the house
uh okay David how's it going David
another Channel member here Ed salmon
Hufflepuff for life
Dr sherbet
okay and see like it just it just
skipped a whole bunch of comments
Jagged wizard
gosh why does it do that man
they are insane Nico your friendly
neighborhood Italian hey how's it going
see now I have to scroll back up and I
have to find where I left off and then
by the time I scroll up there's already
been a ton of things that I've missed so
then I have to scroll back down it'll
win the Jitter sounds like Ellen
DeGeneres okay there we go all right I
just saw Katrina's what's tonight's
disgust discussion
[ __ ] oh that's right Shadow got it got
stabbed in the hand you guys
hand is healing really well that's good
to know
I'm afraid to ask about the story like
I'm afraid to ask how much you can share
hey Jessie with the Super Chat love from
the UK
wow it must be late for you or early
depending on you know
Jesse thank you so much for the Super
Chat and thank you for staying up at
this late hour supporting the channel
and hanging out with us tonight
or this morning for you probably
all right so okay we got the Logan's
Natasha even though the collector's
edition is lackluster I still want it
I have one pre-ordered I was fortunate
enough to get one and I have
I've contemplated canceling the
pre-order but that'd be pointless
because I could always gift it to one of
you guys because I feel like somebody in
the community would really want one so
I'd much rather do that or sell it to
somebody at Cost who really wanted one
then just canceling my pre-order and
letting it go
hoping like you know it's it's a it's a
Fool's hope but I'm hoping that they'll
decide to throw some other stuff in
again I know there's like zero chances
that happening considering they've
already had an unboxing
all that stuff they have to package and
get ready months and months and months
in advance so probably not happening but
I just saw where Chandler wood ordered a
wand from uh
we'll pull we'll pull up his tweet later
and just like the Craftsman's ship on a
lot of these custom wands from like Etsy
stores it's just like
dude it looks so much better than
than what the collector's edition is
doing so much better
all right see when I get all for ambling
like this then I miss too many of the
other comments so
okay I can't hear myself there we go
that's a lot better
geez I was like yelling I didn't have my
uh
I think it's called side tone on the mic
all right here we go rapid fire we got
David Ed okay we said hi to you guys
let's see Cody hey what's up Cody
welcome just found the channel love the
content keep it up can't wait for
Hogwarts like see Cody you're in a group
of like-minded individuals let me tell
you so glad you found the channel
welcome that's what we've all been doing
for oh I don't know the better part of
two years or so now Bender boy I'm gonna
play on PS5 yeah un unless
unless there's like some major type of
uh
technical frame rate issue or something
like as long as it runs at 60 at the
performance mode I'm good
Shadow guided that seems oddly specific
we're gonna have seven companions
prediction
inside info what could it be okay JP
says we'll have a goblin companion also
fig and animals so you think they'll be
considered as companion since we we have
seen fig kind of helping out the player
like we have with um
with natsai and with Sebastian we
haven't seen that with poppy yet I don't
think
Jay Rossi says pick no but hope there
may be more than four
Jagged wizard I think Jagged wizard just
got one of those gifteds welcome Jagged
wizard
all right pilot Joseph in the house love
your stream retro what a great Community
I agree I agree
also looks like a couple of new
subscribers as well thank you to the new
subscribers dropping in
kind of hoping we get uh Jeff how's it
going Jeff kind of hoping we get the
four Mains and maybe a couple that are
specific to our house
[Music]
Ahmad how's it going
Jesse uh what's up
we're getting close guys we're getting
close oh actually we're not good
Shadow says my nephew's named Logan Sam
how's it going Sam King welcome
hey sis Channel member hey sis how are
you
oh man I'm really gonna mess this up
first time here n-i-s-se Zoo
Nissan
I mispronounce it's okay
just don't get me to say
wait I had to second guess because we
joked about it so much last time just
don't get me to say or
see it just that doesn't even sound
right like it doesn't say or doesn't
sound right Levi maze how's it going
more coffee beans 89 poppy killed the
oh my gosh dude poppy killed the
Ravenclaw companion you gotta be kidding
me you gotta be kidding me with this
Callisto made it another Channel member
welcome Callisto chubby C think the
Ravenclaw companion will be very
important to the story yeah that's what
a lot of people are kind of guessing it
could be it could be or maybe it's a
name that we know I've seen that from a
lot of people
which I've I've kind of went back and
forth on it
hey there's Nico with the Discord link
let's go
thanks for doing that Nico Drummer Boy
how's it going nice to see you again as
well
have I seen smile I have not like I said
I'm not really a big horror guy
especially not with movies like some
games that sort of Veer into the horror
territory I'll play
like I played several of the Resident
Evils and I played um bloodborne
but things that are just like they're
purely to scary
I gotta have a little action like
Resident Evil and bloodborne that's
enough action adventure it's not pure
it's it's goal isn't purely to scare you
as opposed to something like Outlast you
know
Aspen Frost welcome to the Stream
house how's it going house in the house
in the house indeed I don't think I've
seen that name before so if this is your
first time here thanks for stopping by
and hanging out go ninja go I definitely
have seen that name before thanks for
stopping back by and hanging out tonight
Jay Rossi passes out some butterbeers
hey I've got a Coke Zero Cherry Coke
Zero actually
I shouldn't be drinking caffeine this
late man
but at least it's zero you know
still got the caffeine though
double A Z and turtle hermit welcome
thank you all for hanging out small
buttons and Mary studios here as well
those are two names I recognize thank
you all for being here and hanging out
all right I think okay now we're
definitely getting close no caps Channel
member welcome dude
and Drummer Boy
Jay Rossi
okay I think we're caught up Frank I
missed Frank I believe
don't worry it's Danish and no one can
pronounce it
gotcha
well I'll try my best I'll try my best
we have some fun discussions on
pronunciation here it's all good
it's all good
all right we're fully caught up guys
thanks so much for being here and
hanging out tonight hope you enjoyed the
little Halloween Vibe we got going on we
got some more surprises here on the next
screen for you
[Music]
how are you welcome to Gryffindor yo
there we go we got a 171 viewers right
now 66 likes 21 new channel members
welcome
here we go wait is this here we go real
time right here
CJ just became a member
[Music]
somebody gifted more
no way we had these all just pop in like
that
or wait maybe it's
something weird is going on there these
are the gifteds from a while ago right
it's like when I change the scene
they all started popping through
[Music]
regardless welcome to the new members
welcome thank you for being here
Gabe how's it going
hit that like button if you want to stay
safe from poppy right
I see it's like when I switch scenes
we're getting all of the oh my gosh
they're all gonna play again
why would it do that
[Music]
why would it play them all again
I mean I'm fine with it you all get to
see your name pop up again everybody's
like dang they're getting mad gifted
memberships tonight
foreign
yeah I just don't know why it's popping
them a second time welcome to Gryffindor
we'll have to figure it out I have to
figure it out later
centaripene would be awesome
and that one I think there's a decent
chance of that because at the very least
we know at some point they're gonna be
fighting on our side
because of that glitch scene that they
shared
where the Centaur just like flies off
into
space no I'm his dad hey Norma's Dad
how's it going welcome back I do
remember seeing that name
yeah I think it's uh I think it's a 20
yeah 21 is what it's saying right here
so all those were repeats for some
reason
no idea why it pops up another time
miss that glitch scene Mary it was it
was a while back they shared it on the
Twitter in fact I can't remember if
that's one that just Chandler shared
or if it's one that
they also shared on the main account too
but yeah so new video hit today on the
channel if you guys haven't seen it
retro record or youtube.com retro reckon
tour
and it's basically a breakdown of all
the latest
uh like story news that came out as a
result of these little cards
so kind of jumping back to September
30th as we get into the news here this
was what they released that little video
that recapped everything to do with the
field guide
so all the tips
and it I mean I don't know I was hoping
that's why I didn't put out the
thumbnail today for the little uh live
stream countdown I was hoping we would
get something this afternoon
because they've been pretty consistent
they really have they've been pretty I'm
sorry I don't mean to get off track why
is Tom Nook trending
back
why is Tom Nook trending
fans of the online game Animal Crossing
discuss character Tom Nook
okay I really wish there's gotta be a
way to I wish I could just I love Tom
Nook I love Animal Crossing but I I
don't I don't care a lot of times about
what's trending I wish I could just hide
it
there's got to be a way to hide this
come on Twitter anyway so they had been
on a pretty steady Pace they tweeted out
um this was kind of the compilation of
all the Instagram posts that they had
shared
and then last week they sort of went to
an every other day
first we got Sebastian
so if you guys didn't see this yet we
learned the name of Sebastian's sister
her name is Anne and also that they are
twins Sebastian and his sister Anne are
twins
dude ladies and gentlemen
Stargazer Tim in the house
and star Geezer Tim just gifted five
more membership star Geezer Tim thank
you so much star Geezer welcome to
Gryffindor dude Jay Rossi just got a
gift of membership
guys happy for everybody but Jay Rossi
I'm especially happy for Jay Rossi J
Rossi's been here hanging out and I
think every single stream that we have
done so I am super excited to see that
Jay Rossi got one of the gifted
memberships congrats to Jay Rossi and
all the others who just got gifted and
thank you so much Tim uh both uh I
mentioned Nico earlier helping out with
the Discord so Tim Nico and Dylan are
um really kind of giving me a lot of
good ideas on the Discord so their
moderators over on the Discord and both
Dylan and Nico are moderators here I'm
probably gonna need to add one or two
more moderators here on the YouTube
channel as well
but um yeah so huge huge supporters of
the community supporters of the stream
supporters of the Discord so Tim good to
see you here tonight hanging out Phillip
Elder yo I recognize Philip's name from
uh Twitter Philip how's it going Phil
just got one of the gifted memberships
let's go
and I saw um I saw Macy that's a good
point Macy we should probably uh let me
open up a separate tab here that's the
cool thing about stream elements is that
welcome to Gryffindor
you have to oh my gosh why does it look
so
I'm gonna go and uh she suggested that I
move the
all the little alerts above the screen
that's a good point so they pop up there
over my logo instead of over whatever
content we happen to be looking at at
the time and the one thing like
I do have to figure out why all of them
popped up a second time we'll have to
test that later in the Stream like when
we get close to the end I'll go back to
the full cam screen and we'll see if
they pop again
because we're getting some new ones now
here on this screen all right so let's
go into streaming tools here my overlays
and this overlay is called our
commentary overlay
all right so I'm going to move it
I'm gonna move it
nope not that one
all right let's see
alerts okay that's what I need to move
oh my gosh no come on stream elements I
was I was literally literally just
hyping you up
saying how user friendly and how oh no
it's like moving my whole screen now
okay there we go I got it I got it I got
it
all right now I'm going to test one so
this one right here is not a legit oh
wait first I need to save it
all right this one that's about to pop
up
oh my goodness did you guys see that
just saw a ghost go by all right I'm
gonna test this right here this is not a
real subscriber
okay I can drop it down a little bit
drop it down just a little bit
so we get Hagrid in there
oh my gosh dude it's like trying to
select layers
why why must you be so difficult
and see I shouldn't try to do this live
that's the other problem
I was like oh it'll be no problem it'll
be no problem guys
zero problem
it's trying to do too much just trying
to do too much
teal side
don't think I've seen that name before
welcome
nearly headless Nick going off right now
right he's just on repeat
he's just on repeat
uh villigant Beast don't know if this
has been said but the last line on
Poppy's description seems to imply that
we can side with the poachers took it as
a warning but it could be reading too
much into it oh yeah we're definitely
gonna read out read through some of
these again
and we'll talk about uh what I think
they could mean because they've they've
all been kind of varying levels of
revealing if that makes sense like some
of them have like I feel like Sebastian
that was a pretty interesting info Nat's
eyes were probably was probably the most
revealing but it was mostly just dealing
with her backstory whereas Poppy's
barely said anything uh at least at face
value barely said anything all right
we're gonna try this one more time to
adjust
if this doesn't work though
then I'll just do it later it's fine
oh that's why okay
I'm just using arrow keys instead of
trying to use the mouse
I think this is working a lot better
all right I'm Gonna Save that hopefully
that'll be good
if it's not hey there with the ghost
again
Lily Potter should I give my own
channels a new name
uh what do you mean are you are you
talking
are you trying to like build a uh
YouTube
twins makes this such a more interesting
storyline
right
see the Great Hall decked out in spooky
decor for sure for sure
hope they show a video of the Great Hall
when it's Halloween as I was setting up
for this stream and like getting all the
little fun spooky things going
I was thinking about that too
that would be such a fun thing they
absolutely have to do something on
Halloween they can't let Halloween go by
without giving us some sort of uh new
drop of info I saw somebody suggesting
fall ASMR
I like that I like that A Lot Fall ASMR
would be really good
and and especially if it shows some of
the themed decorations Maybe
around the around the castle oh that'd
be so good
that'd be so good
headless hunt ASMR
Jenny says loving the spooky grooves
tonight hey I know right I found this
right before we started going live you
guys want to check this out haunted
house Lo-Fi hip-hop Lo-Fi geek
and so it's also in the video
description if you guys want to check it
out
oh
foreign
I used to
YouTube got far too tricky with YouTube
rules on copyright nonsense yeah there
most of the time on my
on the videos that I pre-record it's not
really a problem
on these the live streams I have gotten
a couple of not strikes but uh what do
they call them copyright claims
and I'm pretty sure they've all been
bogus claims because all the music that
I use is from copyright free sources now
like this one that I'm using tonight
their only stipulation is that you have
to put it in the description
so that's easy enough to do right put it
in the description but then I've had
some others that don't even have that
requirement and I still I've gotten some
random name
claiming the video
and there's a process you can go through
but I've just been clipping it out
because it's it usually is from that
beginning part of the Stream So YouTube
does give you the ability to go back in
even though the video is already up and
I can just clip that out so usually what
I'll do is I'll just cut out the whole
first 10 minutes because for anybody
watching the VOD there's no point in
having the countdown anyway honestly I
should just get in the habit of doing
that after every live stream but as far
as the videos go it hasn't been too
difficult let's knock on wood not yet
anyway when I first got started I tried
to include because I've seen a lot of
these channels that use a bunch of Harry
Potter movie clips
and I thought oh you can use movie clips
and you know it's fair use as long as
you're having commentary and all that
but YouTube has an auto detect system
and so if you let too much of it play
the auto detect system will catch it
so I've gotten to where I barely use any
movie clips and if I do they're just
very very minimal
so it's mostly all my voice and gameplay
gameplay of games
trailers that sort of thing
hey high IQ Warrior welcome how's it
going dude
careless dreamer are you is that sarcasm
Hagrid's Family's last name is is Hagrid
yeah Hannah his last his name is rubius
Hagrid keeper of keys and games and
Hogwarts
Moon Lily I kind of want to dedicate a
video about the care of magical
creatures dying to know if unicorns are
in Game and if we can interact
if they are they have I mean they're
they're rare right so they have to be
they have to be really really rare
but I did see
so I gotta give credit to James on this
there is another
[Music]
Havelock Sweeting
you guys seen this
Havelock Sweeting
a unicorn expert
born in 1634 died in 1710
this could be
let's see hold on this is this is hard
math so born in 1634
if he could have had kids you know
anywhere from
1654 or so 1650 to like
1670
[Music]
so this could be the probably like great
great grandfather of Poppy
that's yep that's what I was thinking
Drummer Boy my math could be off but I'm
thinking great great grandfather or
something yeah
so we already have the setup
plus we know that Poppy is
Adept at
working with magical creatures
unicorns have a distrust of males I
think you're right about that Mary I
think you're right
dumb moment
hey all good careless no worries
Gabe man the people the people spoke I I
wanted to give everybody the option
because I thought you know what people
may not want
they might not want look at this guys if
you go to our community page
I mean it couldn't have been more
overwhelming
I thought we might get a decent amount
for a one in gameplay
but even if I combine god of war and
Spider-Man nope you guys just want to
recap the news even though there's
nothing new
all good with me
all good with me
but I do want to start doing more
gameplay streams as well I really do I I
have a lot of fun doing gameplay streams
the problem is they're just not nearly
as as interactive
they're they're
they're more interactive than Let's
Plays but they're not as interactive as
this because I I mean you guys see how
how hard it is for me to keep up with
chat right now
but when you're playing a game I mean
that that lowers the ability to
check chat even more
star Geezer Tim hey have a good night
all good Tim I know I I I'm burning the
not quite the Midnight Oil but it's late
night hours for the Retro stream
so I totally get if people have to hop
out early but I thank you for stopping
by Tim and for the gifted memberships
two kind of you too kind you know what
I'm gonna turn down the music a bit too
or maybe I just need to I'm just gonna
turn it down in my ears because it's
already pretty
pretty low on your all's end
have like a poppy pretty much the same
name
ether welcome back as well or no no no
ether
ether
see I second guessed myself now
that's over 100 years before Hogwarts
Legacy when he died depends on Poppy's
parents age right right
developers have put so much thought
indeed like I don't know how I'd
I hadn't heard this one at all I'd
completely missed this one and I had
went through
and I remember looking at like all the
wizard cards but I just
this one completely bypassed me
did not catch this one at all which I
don't think this one was
um I don't think this one was in the
video game somebody might maybe be able
to correct me on that but like if you're
on the Lexicon here they have this FW so
the famous Witch and Wizard cards and if
you hit the link
it has a little description here of
when these were released
so after the release of the fourth book
The World of Harry Potter expanded
dramatically rolling so the film rights
additional information
rather than let others create it Roland
did it herself 101 famous wizard cards
the result of were the result of that
effort
there are three types of cards available
the first is the Harry Potter Trading
Card Game
so wait where's the second
the second
trading cards with photos from the films
and then the third are the famous wizard
cards the ones Joe was talking about on
her site these cards have appeared in
several forms okay so these are the
video game ones gotcha
show you some of the information from
the famous Witch Wizard chocolate frog
cards for her websites wizard of the
month
oh yeah back when they did The Wizard of
the month
so yeah I don't know which
at which point this card was dropped but
that definitely looks like a video game
it looks like an asset from one of the
video games
but I agree Joseph a lot of thought into
this game
Hermione the time Turner Channel member
welcome Hermione
oh Nico now Nico getting in on the
gifted membership party
why is there a delay see it's like
sometimes there's a delay
there it goes there it goes and it's
always the members that pop first then
the one who did the gifting I don't know
why it's like that Nico dude thank you
so much for your support of the stream
and those of you who just got a gifted
membership congratulations make sure you
thank Nico uh and now you get access to
the emojis in the chat
you also get discount on our merch
priority reply and comments on the
retro record tour YouTube channel
and my thankfulness thank you guys so
much that's awesome
Drummer Boy I feel like if we choose the
evil choice to join the bad people in
the side quest we face him as the final
battle for the Side Story if we have AK
unlocked before we do them who knows
what will happen interesting
yeah I they threw me off ever since they
said there's no
morality system
because there's so many degrees of what
a morality system could be
so I yeah I still I mean there are
definitely gonna be choices and they're
definitely going to have impact right
but they kind of threw me off when they
when they said that
Jedi Master Tyler in the house welcome
Jedi Tessa
how's it going Tessa
CT 707 wolf Trooper oh dude another
Slytherin man
another Slytherin it's all good it's all
good oh Hermione that you were Lily okay
gotcha
gotcha
Bradley was gifted one like 20 minutes
ago nice
Mary says lack of love interest is an
interesting choice BioWare spoiled my
expectation of that yeah I made a video
on that a while back and that was a very
divisive topic seems like
because we're dealing with underage kids
basically
teenagers kids you know our character is
going to be 15. I think they could
definitely do it and I think they could
pull it off in a way that's tasteful and
not weird or creepy I still think there
will be I mean we already know the
companions we're going to have some sort
of relationship bond that we develop
with them maybe it just won't be a
romantic relationship
um but I I still think there's a chance
that there there could be some level of
like I don't know going on dates or
something to bond to get closer to
people
certain characters
and I heard uh I I know uh Hogwarts
mystery has it so I mean it could
definitely be be done
thank you Jedi Master very much
appreciated
could go the route of persona 5. yeah
yeah persona 5.
that's an interesting way of handling it
yeah
a good example although that one
That's rated M so that one kind of they
can skirt the line a little bit more I
don't think Hogwarts Legacy is going to
be rated M and I feel like the Persona
characters are a little bit older
but I do still think that's a good
framework that they could kind of work
work backward from
yo feathers here in the house as well
how's it going feathers welcome
yeah I think so too Mary I think so too
probably be someone like Bully meets
Persona 5. I need to watch a let's play
a bullying I I'm always ashamed to say
that I've ever played it it gets brought
up so many times by people in Hogwarts
Legacy conversation
all right so we talked about Sebastian
we talked last week about the
possibility of uh blood maledictus
for the curse so I'm not going to talk
much more about that but we did not get
to talk about Nat's side yet this is a
big one guys
wise quick-witted possessive a need to
seek Justice Nats I grew up in oh wait
hold on I looked this up last night
Mata belly land I think it is matabelle
land Africa where she attended wagadu
the largest Wizarding School in the
world she transferred to Hogwarts when
her mother became the school's
divination professor and is adapting to
her new life in Scotland so that one a
lot of big reveals divination just about
confirmed I think we already knew about
the Divination tower now we know we have
the identity of the Divination Professor
we had seen her in the background but
now we know Professor actually it could
be a different last name
it could be a different last name but
possibly professor onai as the
Divination professor
and then we we know that natsai also is
immediately going to have a special bond
with us because of the fact that we're
both starting out Hogwarts together
which is uncon you know as a fifth year
I'm trying to think did we ever
in the Harry Potter series did we ever
have a transfer student
or was it always just new
like a new wave of First Years now there
are characters that were barely
mentioned in other books that we were
introduced to
but I'm trying to think did we ever have
a transfer in the series
Moon Lily says not that I yeah I can't
think of one
Malfoy talked about it
Nats I might have started the previous
year
ah you're right it doesn't say
that's a good point
I totally in my head read that as that
they are just that this is her her
mother's first year and her first year
as I grew up
in mate
bellaland Africa where she attended
wagadu okay so she we know she at least
attended one year there that's all we
know transfer to Hogwarts when her
mother became the school's divination
professor and is adapting that's a good
point it does not tell us when
it does not tell us exactly when
bill was gonna transfer if it didn't
have the money ah no transfers as far as
I'm aware yeah I couldn't think of one
either but yeah that's a good point
Jenny I'm glad you said that I've I've
been taking it and running with it that
ahead now I don't know which one I feel
like is more likely
I don't know which one I feel like is
more likely Is she starting out with us
now Jay Rossi with another good point
isn't natsai the one who says to us in
the trailer so you are the new student I
think so yeah
I think so and that doesn't sound like
something that
a new a current new student would say
so you're the new student yeah you
wouldn't say it like that it'd be like
so you're new too or something
so you're also new here I feel like
would be a another way of saying it
somebody was asking about do you think
they'll make cards like this for all
professors
no I I was at first I was thinking maybe
for companions but I definitely could
see it being something that they use to
uh yo speaking of Philip there he is
Philip in the chat Philip here on
Twitter what's up Phillip
doing like a double take there wait I I
just saw you Chad over here now there
you are over there
a and a good a good comment from Philip
2 here
we'll talk a little bit more about
wagadu here here in a second for why
why Philip is is bringing this up here
but Nightwing sings Malfoy talked about
that's right his parents wanting him to
transfer to Durham string
Dustin hoping for M rated I just can't
imagine I just I would be stunned if
they don't hit a t rating now could
could they very well make this game to
be an M absolutely
but I I fully expect it will be a t
rating here
how does a transfer student work with
the book of acceptance so their name was
probably in there all along but
they don't necessarily they could start
at another school
book of acceptance and quill of
admittance I think it is
yeah Draven saying the same thing Jay
Ross he was talking about their hope
Nancy has been there for a year
she might know Wallace magic right yeah
yeah that's what that's what Philip was
talking about here
that's another good question Philip are
the years at the African School
structured the same way we don't know
that either I don't believe
I don't believe that we do
yeah definitely possible that she's been
there for more than one year
transferred to new actors right
Charlie was intending to study oh yeah
yeah somebody said somebody mentioned
that as well
be cool store for the story if NASA
unlocks her mother's private lessons
okay
I talked about this in the video today
but now that we're all here together
I wanna
talk about it more with you all as well
because oh no I don't want the wiki I
want I want the direct source here I
want the direct source
all right so this was the official
Pottermore posting January 2016.
all right so
the whole thing is is actually really
interesting
but a couple of uh the key ones right
here so this one here
actually let's just start right
here okay let's start with this one
much some would say all magic originated
in Africa and wagadu graduates are
especially well-versed in astronomy
Alchemy and self Transfiguration so my
thinking is if if Africa is quite
possibly the origination
of magic itself
It's gotta be another stronghold of
ancient magic just has to be
so
Maybe
Professor onai just call her professor
onai until we hear otherwise
maybe she is going to play a role in
helping our character
figure this out now we already know
about fig we know fig is kind of the one
who's taking us under his wing so it
seems
but because of that connection and I
also talked about if we're gonna get an
anime guy at all
It's gotta be from uh
maybe they'll at least have someone else
like maybe Nat size an anime GI that'd
be kind of cool
because they say right here even as
young as 14.
14 year olds who could turn at will into
elephants and cheetahs
students from wagadu that's how good
they were
but yeah and we know that ancient magic
doesn't always have to be like it can be
without a wand
so yeah I like I like where your
thoughts are at there Bradley I think
that could be cool
natsai is seeking Vengeance the last
divination Professor we know was taken
in by Dumbledore for protection was
Nancy's mom taken in for protection and
does she seek Justice against those who
maybe killed her family right like
there's no mention of a father
and
that's leading a lot of people to say
did her father suffer some injustice
whether he was killed or something else
entirely
yeah we don't know but but that word
justice like that does make you think
like somebody wronged
her family in some way
and then it seems like in that Autodesk
trailer
that trailer was so short it's really
hard to glean much from it
but
yeah she was definitely trying to get
somewhere to get some information and
the hippogriff just seemed to be like a
a side thing I feel like
hoping is different from expecting right
right right
exchange student uh I don't remember
that at all
Dumbledore offered that those students
were welcome after carcroft
ran away oh we did but we never I don't
think we ever heard about any of them
like joining
nah I don't think so Moon Lily I don't
think so
I mean imperio that one's not going to
be terribly graphic honestly like Avada
Kedavra is less graphic than a gunshot
you think about
you think about that in video games like
Uncharted and stuff that still maintain
a t rating
yeah
now there are some scenes where
I think we can see blood in some scenes
with some Wizards in the trailer if you
slow it down and back in the old old
leaked trailer
there was like a I think it was a an ax
going right into the head of a goblin
yeah I see a lot of you guys talking
about ancient magic possibly being
without a wand yep
Nikki says wandless magic would not be
good in my opinion
uh what what do you mean I'm not sure
what you mean by not be good
Ravenclaw says Harry could do one less
magic he was taught to nurture
wasn't taught to nurture it and grow it
yeah
was she there for long enough to become
an anime guy I mean if if they were
learning as early as 14
you you assume she's around the same age
as our character in this game which is
15 but
so yeah maybe she what if she's been at
Hogwarts for a couple years then maybe
she hasn't been
maybe she didn't have enough time but
her mom definitely
definite possibility
killing curse implies we can kill others
and we don't know how dark that path may
be thought they might not go too far
well yeah and it's like
the the act of taking the life
it's kind of weird to think about right
but it's not that's not really
considered a mature
component of game at least in the ESRB
scale of things
so there's no actually actually no blood
with AK it's very AK is like a peaceful
way to go up compared to the uh incendio
that we see in the trailer
don't think each companion will teach us
I'm glad you brought that up gaming uh
Arius 95 in my opinion Sebastian teaches
us
uh crucio Nancy teaches Transfiguration
Wallace magic and or divination poppy
teaches us about creatures mounts
yeah I feel like a lot of people are and
it's a possibility jumping on this idea
of three companions three unforgivables
I don't think so
I don't think so but again I mean I'm
just I'm just guessing with that I just
don't feel like I mean for all the jokes
about poppy being evil and despite the
very Sinister image that they used of
her I can't I can't imagine someone like
Poppy
I can't say it I can't say that though
because
I mean guys
we get we gotta we gotta look at this
we gotta look at this oh wait where'd
you go
where'd you go I lost it
they knew what they were doing they they
knew what they were doing with this they
did
I mean look at this
look at this
dude she looks so much older
she looks so much older than she does in
that Gameplay trailer
I wonder if they've aged up her
character model too or if they were if
this is just having some fun with fans
knowing how the joke has been going
around about poppy being evil but listen
to this all right let's listen to this
Poppy's a bright and compassionate girl
extensive knowledge of being a deep love
for creatures in fact she believes
creatures have far more redeeming
qualities than most people
so that alone tells us like she does
have this sort of Rift between her and a
lot and most people says most people
right here
now in the trailer like she has such
that soft little voice
and she seems so kind and sweet
but
the fact that she is
kind of this
person who doesn't really want to have a
lot to do with people and has a
particular aversion to poachers and
those who work with him whoever said
that earlier about
that seeming like a choice thing to you
and her possibly turning against us if
we could if we could potentially side
with the poachers
you could very well be onto something I
hadn't thought about that but listen
listen to that again and those who work
with them
oh that's kind of a sneaky
sneaky little bit of phrasing right
there
but I can't look at that and I can't
read that and say there's no way she
would use a vodka diver I was getting
ready to say it
but then I thought no if she if she sees
someone harming a magical creature
uh like think Sorcerer's Stone Voldemort
drinking the Unicorn Blood if she was to
walk up to that happening
oh man
and she knows AKA
I can see her doing it I can see her
doing it I could
isn't this the year the potions
championships at Hogwarts
ah you have to refresh my memory on that
Drummer Boy is this a specific thing
from Canon or are you talking about like
something that happened in Harry's fifth
year
Bradley do we know what fig teaches we
do not a lot of guesses for ancient
runes and or Transfiguration
ancient runes for obvious reasons he's
the one who's helping us learn about
ancient Magic
Transfiguration it probably is the one
that's
we just don't know as much about yet
and we saw it in that we saw an object
being transfigured in the first trailer
uh Neko or Nico not not sure if I'm
pronouncing it correctly noctis late to
the stream also first time catching
alive hope everyone is excited yo you're
in the right place you are in the right
place let me tell you that's all we got
here is excitement for this game
that's not all we got but we got a lot
of it trust me we got a lot of that
excitement for this game
could easily be a dark yeah yeah it
could still be a dark game and be rated
teen
main consists was AK was a finisher
that's my guess Dustin yeah
a Twist on animagi WE willingly become
an animal by taking on the burden of ant
salad to free hair ooh like some sort of
ancient magic twist Nats I won't be
teaching me a thing won't be friends
with anyone not in Slytherin oh my
goodness dude Draven draven's like going
all Malfoy
what is it he says to uh don't he says
to Harry you don't want to go making
friends with the wrong suit
whoa that's cool Phantom the whole
African Africa being the origin of magic
is in reference to The Magicians in
Egyptian mythology and the
self-transfiguration references the
animal-headed gods of Egypt oh
interesting
trying to go to the trail wizard
tournament yeah that's a big request
that's a big request for sure
[Music]
hey Levi good to see you as well thanks
for hanging out have a good night
she definitely looks older all of them
that's a good point too feathers all of
them do look a little bit older but
especially Poppy
Nat's eye I could see it with natsai for
sure too Sebastian I haven't
a little bit a little bit
I feel like Sebastian a little bit
natsai a little bit more I don't know
why everything is loading so slow for me
tonight
's eye a little bit more but then poppy
just looks so much older
and she could have passed for like a
second year in the in the trailer
poppy is going to be sweet but have an
angry side
right like I could see her snapping dude
I could absolutely see her snapping
use the Aging potion
trailer got the sense that she was a
year or two behind us exactly that was
my thought as well
herpo the foul nah Poppy the putrid
right
he's gonna AK some poachers I could see
it big evil I could see it after reading
that description and then putting that
face with it I mean all jokes all jokes
aside about the Poppy's evil stuff
we already know Sebastian is kind of
pushing this idea of you know should the
unforgivable curses really be
Unforgivable
in every circumstance
which even though hair the the Harry
Potter books didn't really explore that
they kind of did in a way because Harry
ended up using two of them
I mean he kind of failed at using one of
them but imperio they were just like
yeah whatever
book seven oh we kind of got to do this
so imperio
for the greater good am I right
Grindelwald
so I do think that idea is very
interesting if they explore that
she does not look like a sweet Badger
poppy anymore
that's that's what I'm getting at Wolf
stripper that's what I'm getting at like
I could see her becoming if something
really bad goes down involving magical
creatures and we already know there are
poachers in this game and there's we've
seen a couple of scenes
uh yeah she could quickly spiral out of
control
extreme is drummer boy yeah right yeah
she could really take it to the extreme
never mess with a Hufflepuff
you turn against her she's the last boss
and you choose whether to AK or not oh
my gosh
dang we going really dark on here the in
the the final game choice is whether or
not you AKA Poppy
wow
could have been bullied a lot maybe
that's like what's sort of driven her
away it's another interesting thought
poppy has a sort of poison ivy Vibe
going on instead of plant she's
passionate about protecting animals oh
that's that's an interesting comparison
too
tells us she beats people up for abusing
animals right she's gonna like the
Loyalty Factor she is loyal to the
magical creatures
now James expected goes been calling her
like our version of Newt which
I think is is the best comparison I
think it's a good comparison I do but
then they have to go out and they post
this image right here
we've never seen any pictures of Newt
looking this angry
oh man
could off a human to save a creature I
wouldn't put it past her
probably could be like Sebastian do
whatever helping you could yeah yeah
yeah
potions Championship was in 1890.
where where is this
I haven't I don't think I've ever heard
of this
was this something like Slughorn talked
about
all right here we go HP lexicon
The Wizarding schools potions
Championship was a competition held to
challenge potion makers to prove their
potion making skills by completing
various challenges and Brewing various
potions the winner received a gold
cauldron
oh do they not have any dates on it
oh so wait this all came about from that
whole zigmund budge look of potions
thing
the championship is held in an enchanted
garden students use their potioneering
skills to overcome various obstacles
including Fantastical beasts while
working to win the golden cauldron for
Hogwarts
blizzarding school's potion Championship
is held every seven years and has been
held since 1407.
wait they didn't have it in Harry
Potter's day did they
one of the winners of the competition
was a Hogwarts student who used zigmund
budge's book of potions to help secure
the win competitors of the Hogwarts
Champion were a Russian not even gonna
try to pronounce that
um oh look at this look at this look at
this
wagadu student
oh wait so when is when is this one
the competitors of the Hogwarts okay
wait so this was the Hogwarts champion
this was
the people competing against them this
competition and the new information
release related to is from the Wonder
book book of potions a video game
released by Sony and Pottermore in 2013
based on the book of Potions by zigmund
budge so then I guess people have just
done the math
from 1407 if it was held every seven
years
we just don't know I'm assuming we don't
know when it stopped being held
poppy using imperio to uh yeah
I wonder if our only path
wonder if not only our path changes with
our choices but our choices change the
paths of others too
now that'd be really interesting yeah if
it not only has I hope so I mean I hope
it not only has consequences for us but
for the characters around us
I'd be down for that feathers I think
that'd be awesome
in the Sebastian trailer someone says
you've made your choice indeed yep
figured Weasley teaches us
Transfiguration
yeah I think she could be to me that
makes the most sense Weasley is
Transfiguration and then uh fig as
ancient runes
[Music]
all good Jake No Worries
yeah try wizard tournament wasn't
happening
I feel like these pictures have
companions
is that we fail a mission or something
thinking of Dragon Age like it could be
loading screens yeah but I'm hoping
there's not a lot of loading screens in
this game
uh Grindelwald is roughly the
he's born around this time
gelat Grindelwald
all right let's see what's the date of
birth
1883 so yeah he's like seven so he
wouldn't be in school yet
you got expelled from Durham string in
1899.
they are dark with poppy
very dark with poppy
Draven Poppy's evil I'm being serious
hitting her with crucio a second I'm
able to
do you think we will have labyrinths
labyrinth-like dungeons
love mazes so much there's not a lot of
them in video games Lee asked hey Lee a
channel member welcome Lee thank you so
much
dude we got Nico here with the Super
Chat
Nico thank you so much for the Super
Chat and the Centaur bug clip Avalanche
shared on Twitter do you think that
provided a glimpse of how our character
will change spells
I was watching a video about this
whose was it I always want to make sure
I give credit I think it might have been
James's
but I know a lot of people made a video
on that
uh if anybody have that link
I'd like to pull it up but I can't
remember the exact tweet if you have
that link Nico we'll pull it up
and I don't think it'll let don't try to
post it in chat unless you're one of the
moderators guys I don't think it'll let
you I think it will block the the post
but yeah I can't if I could pull it up
Nico I don't I can't really answer it
without seeing it because I don't
remember it off the top of my head I
just remember the
I just remember it flying off up above
why no Ravenclaw companion uh it's
coming spin it's coming
yeah I I talked about that in the video
today I I talked to one of the people
who has given me some information
behind the scenes before and it's just a
matter of when
in fact in fact our poll question
tonight let me check in on our poll
question here
nope wrong one
I don't want to move the haunted house I
want to move this one
so let's see what our poll question
looks like
oh why are you
all right we're gonna end the poll here
see
endpole
all right let's see what our final
results were
why is it not showing the final results
oh my gosh
oh wait it's just taking a while to
catch up dude Bradley with a ten dollar
Super Chat hot off the heels of Nico
Super Chat Bradley thank you so much
Bradley didn't even have I'm not even
seeing a question Bradley did did you
only post the uh the Slytherin
icon
Bradley if you have a question feel free
to post it in the regular chat and I'll
try to get to it but if that was just a
show of support for the stream thank you
so much my friend I really do appreciate
that means a lot
all right I was trying to pull up the uh
dude
my computer's acting really weird
tonight guys I hope we don't have
another random crash
I was trying to pull up the
poll results
why is it not letting me
I can't see the poll results they're
just gone
let me try to refresh this page actually
anyway I think it was we only had yes or
no I'm pretty sure it was 68 said yes
that we will have more than four
companions is your prediction
so
the person that told me
that the Ravenclaw companion is just a
matter of oh thank you Moon Lily thank
you so much I don't know why dude it it
just like completely went away
I couldn't see it the moment I hit in
normally it pops up in the Stream oh you
guys must have saw it because all of
your posting there
thank you guys thank you thank you
so yeah there's the poll results there
68 yes 31 no with 320 votes but yeah the
person that told me
the Ravenclaw companion is just a matter
of when not if also said
there will be more than four companions
so there you go there's your little
there's your little tease of the night
now that one is not
I'm not like reporting that it's not
like the Quidditch thing when I was very
very sure on the Quidditch
uh on the Quidditch thing I had that
doubly confirmed on all the stuff that I
talked about with the uh
The Dungeons and all those things I had
that doubly confirmed so I felt really
good about that
this one is just but again it's it's one
of the sources who has told me some of
the stuff already they've been accurate
and reliable so far
honestly I was kind of I'd kind of just
come to accept that we were only gonna
have four I thought it was just gonna be
one for each house
I thought it was just gonna be one for
each house because of how
how they'd been revealing them but if
you really think about it
do we really want to know all of them
before launch
I don't think so I don't
I don't want to know all of them
I'd rather go into the game and and just
be completely surprised by some of the
people that are companions for us
that math isn't adding up I know right
68 and 31.
it's a little uh percent off there
somewhere
close close enough close enough
e-man definitely will I can see the main
ones they've shown are going to be the
important ones and see what I'm
wondering is like does fig count as a
companion
does a centaur count as a companion
because we see fig and from that weird
clip with the Centaur we see the Centaur
as well
and we think they're fighting alongside
us
well we know in the case of fig that
he's fighting alongside us
same with Nat's eye same with Sebastian
and then you would assume Poppy's gonna
be the same
these students and more right feathers
right
feel like super house would be a good
mix well the other thing
I'm just like how much how much should I
say and drop tonight the other thing
that the person was telling me
is that
it's not necessarily based on
houses
and they did they didn't really go into
more detail but but I think in our mind
as fans we were kind of thinking oh it's
it's sort of based around houses
but they were saying it's not so much
based around houses it's more based on
like personality traits
so I was like okay that's that's
interesting yeah
but
I was asking about the Ravenclaw thing
because I was like I was kind of getting
worried I really was I felt so confident
it was honestly I was still pretty
confident but when when last last week I
thought oh this is it they're leading up
to the Ravenclaw companion reveal that's
the point of all this that's the point
of all this build up this week and then
they started going every other day and
so we're all doing the math thinking
like oh darn it's gonna end with the
just the three isn't it
so then when that didn't happen I
reached out to the person I said hey
is there Ravenclaw kabine
and they said yes they've heard there
definitely is
so there you go
there you go and
there's more than four is what they were
saying so that'd be cool I hope so but
yeah I hope we don't get all of them
no uh they did not announce the
Ravenclaw companion not officially yet
I have just heard behind the scenes that
there will be one
for that was wedding zero zero who asked
that Travis not optimistic for more than
uh four but I'm really stoked if that
ends up being true yeah I'm pretty
pretty confident in that but again I
don't know the extent of
of what a companion I mean we know we
kind of have a little bit of an idea of
like how these companions are going to
work
but I still don't think we have that
system fully fleshed out but we know
that it's optional
and to me the whole the whole
when you consider that fact the fact
that Sebastian's Quest is optional then
you gotta have more than four
you would almost have to have more than
four
now of course Sebastian's gonna have
multiple quests but
I mean you would hope for six seven
eight would be great I mean it's an open
world action RPG right
maybe the game wants you to be Ravenclaw
I saw that going a lot of people been
saying that hippie and there was that
going around on uh Twitter I'm pretty
sure that was just a Photoshop that was
just a Photoshop
that comment about the uh
Ravenclaw companion where somebody had
I'm almost positive that was just a
Photoshop somebody having a little fun
you all know everyone's talking about
someone teaching us AK what if no one
does what if you find it while in a
dungeon it does say be careful where you
choose to explore oh it does it does
Phantom
one part in the state of place has
allies and shows the main character
conversing with a white-haired goblin I
was thinking that too JP yes thank you
for bringing that up yes
I could see a goblin companion as well
yeah the goblin that we're meeting with
in the uh Hog's head I believe
I wonder why they're putting so much
focus on these three companions
uh I don't know I mean maybe it's just
kind of the three that they've
chosen to highlight for whatever reason
maybe it's the one that they have the
most information on so far in terms of
the game like the most most of the stuff
done
Hannah with the Super Chat Hannah thank
you so much for the Super Chat there
Hannah says other companions probably
recognize their names that's definitely
possible it's definitely possible we
could we could very well have some
um
like a Ravenclaw companion where we
recognize their last name maybe that's
the reason that they're holding back
yeah maybe you could choose any
companion but the main story has only
three peeves is a companion confirmed
yeah you heard it here first retro
record tour no
own house self companion
what do we know about Deke
be like a companion as well
oh
I think you were I do think Deke works
at Hogwarts
but Deke that's another companion
there's Deke there's Goblin there's a
centaur
okay here we go Nico found it let's go
dude thank you so much Nico all right
are you sure you want to leave YouTube
oh I trust Nico but
just in case something goes crazy with
that link
I'll open it up separately oh yeah yeah
here it is Mary studios are you still
here Mary Mary said she had missed this
Amore poet what is up a Maury poet
what have I missed the last week and a
half so out of the loop now oh Maury
poet you gotta go back and uh well
actually you know what Maury poet here
if you go to
go to go to my go to the YouTube watch
today's video right here that's that is
almost an exact recap of the last week
and a half
almost exactly
welcome Amore poet good good to hear you
good to hear you good to see you
hanging out in the chat so
Mary and others who hadn't seen this
before this was all the way back in
March I knew it was a while ago
and it was the WB Games I knew it was in
like an obscure
this is WB Games Avalanche account while
putting together last week's trailer we
came across this hilarious bug and had
to share
okay so it's only nine seconds long
but look at this uh Twitter compression
too
so you could you could see the Centaur
over here
and then you can see our character doing
battle we've seen this this setting in
the trailer before
clearly doing battle here with these
dark Wizards and it looks as if the
Centaur over here is helping and then
this one you're gonna see the crazy
glitch right here so look there's the
Centaur helping and then this one just
goes flying
oh just got confringo in the face I'm
gonna turn down the music or pause the
music here so you all can uh
make sure this is turned up so everybody
can hear this
because there's no audio I I or there's
there is audio there's no music I kind
of like this better at least for trying
to figure out
could freak out direct it
so what is that ha ha
is that in game it sounds like Siri or
something
uh but Nico was asking do I think this
shows a sneak peek at how combat's gonna
work absolutely R1
is clearly used for
um
oh my gosh
I'm drawing a blank now I did another
video I did a video on this where we
talked all about this oh geez a pug no
so to make the object and that's R1
right there
but I want to watch our character here
okay so right there spell then another
spell and then we see this kind of
little sort of bluish white I don't know
purple glow that bounces off of them and
then watch this right here
we get that little like pew pew sound
and our character kind of shakes the
wand
like something is on a cool down
and not active yet
here let's watch it again
so
it dare they shake the wand
so you can see so maybe the centaurs
aren't necessarily companions because
there's more than one here there's one
over here on the left and then we have
this one although they did say it was a
bug so maybe
maybe there's not supposed to be more
than one then this Centaur just goes
flying
gets hit by a confringo
just a random haha that we hear out of
nowhere
don't know what that's all about
Draven I think a lot of people are
thinking that we'll have a set last name
and that we'll get to choose our first
name and then characters in game will
just call us by our last name
or they just
don't say her name
is possible but a lot of games that
handle it both ways
should be a key character in hogsmeade
well if the goblin works or and or lives
in the hog's head or in hogsmead that
would qualify
hopefully we can name our character I
hope so I think we'll be able to name
them at least a little bit
Philip says that is making me think of
the Nemesis system probably
significantly scaled back from Shadow Of
War just deeper unique personalities
what if we find the place where AK was
first used they said our past could lead
us to a dark place and then it shows a
cave and the player using AK yeah that
cave I think is definitely tied to it
to where we learn
Lee says retro are you and Chandler the
same person using different masks both
have blue eyes I've never seen the two
of you in the same place
nah Chandler has a lot more hair than I
do so
unless unless he's you know pulling out
a wig
no no Chandler and I are not not the
same person
I really hate it when the chat like why
did it just jump it just jumps and like
skips 50 posts
I was looking at hallberry's comment
Paul Berry or halberry
where did it go
oh my gosh we got Tom Riddle here though
okay there it is uh hallberry says I
think there will be other companions but
like teachers or Housewives maybe
non-student ones yeah kind of like fig
and maybe others maybe we can influence
our companions to walk away from certain
paths possible possible
I would say we can name our own
character the NPCs won't virtuous by
name example engage and impact they
refer to you as traveler rather than
your name see I could be like student or
I just think
the the Potter series it's just you
think about all the instances of
the students running around and the
teachers shouting their last names like
butter Weasley Granger you know
so it would be cool if we had a set last
name that they would actually say in
game
Ashley wish they would tease the
Ravenclaw companion without a name or
face reveal just to know they exist keep
us in the dark about who they are
I'm pretty confident a Ravenclaw
companion exists yeah we were talking
about that earlier
I I talked to a person behind the scenes
who's shared some info before
and they assured me there is a Ravenclaw
companion and they've been right so far
so I have no reason to doubt them here
our nickname is going to be the ancient
one could you imagine the Ancient One
don't forget Deke yeah we can't forget
about Deke
could find AK and the restricted
Restricted Section we definitely know
we're gonna be able to sneak around the
restricted sections that's pretty cool
really hope some of the animals can be
companions with us never had a better
companion than a dog meat oh
oh right
there have been some really good Animal
Companions in games
that's for sure
if there's subtitles it'll probably say
the name we set audio will say something
else fandom draws in the house Channel
member Phantom draws what's up fandom
Travis cup possibly teachers and
civilians
Amore poet's been on vacation
ah gotcha
well yeah that video of today will catch
you up mainly they've released those
three character cards with some minor
story bits mainly backstory
but some people are starting to feel
like it might be a little bit too much
story stuff they're sharing and they
might need to start making it go a
little bit more toward gameplay which we
know they've said they're going to show
gameplay before the end of the year so
we know that's coming
Shameless plug oh I don't oh for that
for the video yeah yeah
Shameless plug for my own video we can
we can promote it here it's all good
JS we are stoked as well
here for not for long Phantom a it's all
good appreciate you stopping by and
hanging out for as little or as long as
you can be here
just think about the cemetery we saw in
the state of play involves a special
quest with our house ghost or sun
Nicholas
hey we do see that we're going with
Nicholas somewhere
somewhere and the main character says
don't don't
um forget why I'm here sir so we have to
go to Nick for something in one of the
quests now we talk about what they
revealed so far and how some people feel
like a little too much one thing I do
really like is there's been very little
about the main story which I'm
I'm totally cool knowing little about
that
totally cool
before you went on vacation in the know
but now you're not
confringo might be a spell we can learn
too I definitely think so yeah for sure
foreign
specific house quests Nightwing
I don't I could be wrong about that
and I'm kind of torn on whether I would
want to see it or not because on one
hand it does sort of increase
replayability gives you another reason
to replay on all the houses
but man that's four times really
so I'd rather instead them have it to
where it just might play out a little
bit differently
so maybe if there's a quest involving
the Gryffindor something in the
Gryffindor common room well you can just
walk right in if you're a Gryffindor but
if not
you've got to find a way to get in
whether it's a companion that you've
befriended or whether it's poly juice
potion or whether it's some other means
that'd be awesome
that would be awesome
just take a fireball to the Head
[Music]
coach Lewis is so excited for this game
love your commentary hey I appreciate
that
appreciate that
glad you found the live stream
cool down or the spell change animation
ah nature guy a spell change animation
oh that's weird though
why would there be a spell change
animation
no I think it's something like something
not working right with the wand
hey Chris welcome thank you for
subscribing to the channel
but again I mean they were showing this
as a glitch so it may not even whatever
it is may not look like this in the
final game
dude Centaur is just freaking out
totally freaking out
you missed this Amore poet
you missed this while you were away
this is official right here let me tell
you
school night means early bed a that's
very responsible of You Phantom draws
very responsible love you
have never heard that at the end before
I know I watched this before too and I I
do not remember hearing that
what in the world sounds just like Siri
or something
just a flourishment like cast time
almost to cast a pulso perhaps the wand
Shake is a failed cast could be a
cooldown Spell failure would be an
interesting mechanic is this a feature
is it a bug or is it a feature right
one could be a companion and the others
are just fair there for the quest yeah
that's true that's true
Travis it's not the settings it's
it's that I it takes time to respond to
the comments and we have such an active
chat here
that if I talk about any one comment
for more than like 30 seconds
I'm about 20 posts behind
so
that's what it is
oh man I know it feels like that on
urine probably
it feels very uh
delayed but see so much of our
discussion it's just
it's not something you you can respond
to quickly
I mean a few of them are but a lot of
things it's like I wanna I wanna deep
dive on and then by the time I'm done
deep diving there's like
20 more things I want to Deep dive
nose of Sauron maybe the devs will
reveal the Rabel Claw compena at the end
of a Gameplay trailer
yeah maybe the next Trail I mean
Sebastian got a whole trailer so
need something to make choosing certain
houses special besides the robes
let's think about that Nightwing see
here we go this is a perfect example
like I see that comment from Nightwing
and now I want to unpack it and I know I
can see there's already like at least
10 more comments after that I can see
plus probably another 10 to 15 that I
can't that are past the scroll I can't
see them
but that's just how it goes
yeah like what else could they do
to make
to make the houses few I mean that the
the common rooms I mean that's the big
one right but then at the end of the day
is it just a hub and nothing more
what else can they do to actually have
an impact on the gameplay
they did mention apologies you're right
Philip it's it's definitely going to
come into play at some point
foreign
backfired could be yeah
someone titled the clip and it was red
text to speech it because it does sound
like a bot doesn't it
what if there was uh a wheel with spells
he's choosing a new combo set but for
the video they disabled the hood ah
I could see that Nico yeah there's
something there that we just can't see
that's actually happening when they're
going through the different spells so
that's why they put some little
animation with it
could be
what if the wand we're using doesn't
trust us oh my gosh
it's the Elder Wand
we didn't win it right we didn't
rightfully win the wand
okay see right now the chat just did the
thing again where it like jumps way down
nose of Sauron a nose of Sauron have a
good one thank you for stopping by and
hanging out
rave music oh my gosh over the centaur
yeah guys check out the Discord
um which oh man you know what I meant to
do earlier Nico when you shared it I
meant to me go on and create a
I'm gonna create
a command for it
so we were talking about this earlier in
the Stream guys if you want to continue
these discussions
when we're not live streaming Nico has
done an excellent excellent job
revamping our Discord
so there are a lot of new areas in the
Discord and I'm gonna go right now and
I'm going to create
a command for this
chat commands
okay let's see custom command
all right so we're gonna add new command
exclamation point Discord
and then let's see if anybody is
thank you
what is this Jake about going live next
Thursday
next Thursday you're excited to go
live in Texas
what's happening on Thursday
what's happening on Thursday Jake
foreign
like we had to pick up a wand or
something for some reason
Elwyn elwin is back what's up it was a
that's why
everybody's asking Owen about the dogs
Ellen's a dog trainer which is awesome
WB elwin and we can steal others wands
and use them I want to be General
Grievous in Harry Potter now
Ravenclaw Tyrell tried asking earlier
yeah yeah people have people ask me
about that map all the time yeah
yeah I have seen it
amazing detail amazing detail
which Professor is using Polyjuice
[Music]
man
there's a there's a video I'm working on
that
I'll tease a little bit for you guys
that idea got me thinking of it but it's
it's gonna be something about the
possible
twists and
evil characters in Hogwarts Legacy
kind of like a fun
Halloweenish Vibe type of video
dogs are the best indeed someone
mentioned that the descriptions were
where it's
uh State certain characters that can do
things be our companions honestly I
think that could be the case
I wonder if Poppy's gonna be evil or
she's nice but she's crazy when fighting
I mean poppy like look at that face we
were talking about that earlier
I mean poppy could definitely snap in
this game would not surprise me at all
if something bad happens to a magical
creature then
poppy AKA
not gonna surprise me at all
not gonna surprise me
oh you get to go to Universal okay now
it makes sense that is awesome for sure
yeah you gotta check out all the Harry
Potter stuff down there it's great I
haven't been since they opened the new
part but
even what they had originally on the
islands of it so on the Islands of
Adventure side they have Hogwarts and
like hogsmead
that alone was cool then they added on
the other Park the Diagon Alley stuff
so that was incredible
I haven't been to that part so I can't I
still need to go still need to make
plans
interesting to see how many Easter eggs
oh my gosh right not just for the older
games but just for the Harry Potter
series it's gonna be packed it's gonna
be packed with them for sure
yeah yeah I I saw the new map too I
think some people posted that on Discord
Neil it is this right here
it's in the description as well Lo-Fi
geek haunted house Lo-Fi hip-hop mix
no copyright
always always gotta go for the no
copyright
actually I wonder if I could even
I probably don't want to play the
I know it says no copyright but I don't
wanna
I don't want to risk it where I don't
don't have to
oh that's a good idea Nico for us to
have a dog section for well not like
just cute cute uh pet pictures
oh you got an Instagram oh I bet you
have some good ones on there
hit the like button if poppy scares you
careless dreamer oh so you I thought
Okay so
Amore poet saying what was this on our
screen so this was
you probably have seen this Amore poet
but if you haven't seen this they posted
this video on September 30th this was
kind of like a recap of all the stuff
they shared on Instagram this is like
the field guide that they introduced
which is something that we're gonna have
in game
and they they had all these fun little
tips that they revealed with it about
common rooms and various things so then
last week the reveals that we got were
three a lot of us have just been calling
them like player like character cards
because they look like little uh little
trading cards almost here
so the one of Sebastian here not a lot
new but we learned that Anne is his
sister's name and also that they're
twins
then there's one on natsai so we learned
that she is uh also a transfer student
we just don't know when we were talking
about that earlier in the Stream that I
had assumed that she was transferring
this same year with our character
but that's not what it says it doesn't
say when so her mother is also the
Divination professor she attended uh
wagadu for a while grew up in Africa
and then the poppy one
the poppy one didn't reveal a lot of new
info but
it dropped this bit at the end she
believes creatures have far more
redeeming qualities than most people and
has a particular aversion to poachers
and those who work with him
so it's like yeah sweet cute innocent
little Poppy and she also looks very
aged up we were talking about
but I wouldn't put it past her to AK
somebody if they uh harm a magical
creature would not put a pastor at all
nah Neil that doesn't start until uh Tom
Riddle's day
the curse for
the defense against the dark arts post
thousand percent worth that Hannah says
have gone a few times oh to uh yeah all
the parks down there
oh yeah I need to go back I really need
to go back
the last time I went oh my gosh it's
like it's probably been 10 years now
because it was before we had kids and my
oldest son is eight now
so my wife and I we were we were married
when we went
and we went with my family but yeah we
did not have any kids yet so it's been
gosh probably around 10 years that's
crazy
so but yeah so then once we started
having kids there's no point in going
until they're old enough to actually
enjoy it and they're almost there my my
eight-year-old is absolutely there
and then my four-year-old is getting
there I feel like by
I don't want to go in like peak season
like summer so we'll probably try like a
fall
or early winter Maybe
but I think by next year we might be
ready to finally go and of course we we
need to do Disney with them as well
they've never been there either
a Nightwing thanks for stopping by and
hanging out Navy says I have to work
every day oh wow I did not realize
Nightwing you were in the Navy
thank you for your service dude that's
awesome
well yep yeah your sleep is definitely
important
you definitely need your sleep so thanks
for hanging out my friend have a good
one
Nico volunteer with dogs so I have a lot
oh that's awesome I didn't know that
Jaguar gamer that would make sense or we
can let her go down and say go down in
Insanity since it's our choice on what
to do like if we want to know crucio
ether gotta run see you guys in the
Discord hey thanks so much ether
John says one thing I'm not clear on is
that it says we start late as a fifth
year but could that also mean starting
the school year late if we start at the
same time as everyone
John I was wondering that originally too
so a hundred percent we're starting as a
fifth year which is late
I don't think we're starting the school
year late
but
there's gotta be a reason
that we're not arriving by traditional
means
there's got to be a reason
it looks like we are arriving at
Hogwarts when everyone's already there
from the way it looks in the trailer
like almost like they're waiting on us
so I still don't think even if we do get
there late like timing wise of that year
I still don't think it'll be way way
late you know like maybe a couple days
after or the night of maybe we arrived
that night
foreign
tour totally worth it nice I went to oh
my gosh what was it called
I think it was called the Harry Potter
exhibition when it was in New York
and it was where they had a lot of the
movie props my wife and I did that that
was also probably around 10 years ago
tell me man once you have kids like
you're traveling has to change
it's not that you have to stop traveling
but it definitely has to change some of
the things that you used to do you just
can't do until they're a little bit
older
but yeah so we did that that was pretty
fun but they didn't allow I couldn't get
any pictures they didn't allow any
pictures or video in there
but as much as I make fun of cursed
child I would like to see it as a play
just because I've heard as a play it's
actually really good
I'm just gonna imagine in my head that
it's
just a fan fiction fun thing about a
what if Harry Potter
and it is not considered canon in my
book
Elwyn went to Orlando eight years ago
chosen to do the ollivanders experience
giddy to get chosen
over all the 12 year 12 year olds let's
go
see when we went it was still so new
the line for ollivanders was really long
so we never that was the one thing that
we did not get to do that we wanted to
do we did not get to do the ollivanders
experience
but all the other stuff we ate at three
broomsticks we rode all the major rides
which Speaking of of the park how crazy
is that that they part of Hogwarts
Legacy
they modeled after the uh the Hagrid
Hagrid's motorbike ride
you know what let's pull up uh
dude I need I'm gonna definitely have to
restart my computer out after this
everything is running so slow for me
right now
it all started last night I probably
should have restarted it before the
stream but
let's go with
let's go with a hot summer day
Mary I'm sure it will be a whole new
experience going back with his right
exactly
and my oldest
I'm I've been really close to starting
to read Harry Potter with him really
really close but I know once we start
I won't want to stop I want to read all
of them to him so I want to wait till he
gets a little bit older because the
first the first two three he could
definitely handle those but then four
kind of gets a little
that one starts to get pretty dark at
that point
he's only eight but I mean he's
definitely capable of understanding it
for sure at this point I just started uh
he read all the Magic Tree House books
and I would say about 80 of those I read
to him and then about 20 percent he
started reading on his own and then he
just started a new series called uh
heroes in training it's kind of like the
the kid version of Percy Jackson
basically and he's he's just loving him
so far he's reading all those on his own
he's a huge reader I'm I'm so proud of
him he's just he loves to read and he
loves to write he writes all the time
and he's already made up a couple of
different stories that I'm like dude
that's actually a really good character
he has this one series he calls it car
it's called cart and box
so the cart is like a shopping cart so
if you if you can imagine like Pixar
style you know facial animations here
the cart has got animations and then box
rides in the cart
and they go on all these little
adventures together
and then he has another one called um
he calls it Halloween vampire but the
name he started writing it around
Halloween gosh I think he was five or
six
I think he was six when he started
riding it
uh and so he called it Halloween vampire
but his name is Big Tooth this was my
favorite dude I'm so proud I gotta I
gotta share this just very briefly with
you guys so the vampire's name is Big
Tooth he lives
um and he doesn't have any friends
nobody wants to be friends with him
because he's a vampire
so just think about like a six-year-old
mind you know writing this nobody wants
to be friends with him because he's a
vampire
and so he uh he has his house it turns
out he discovers that his house can can
fly it's basically like a spaceship
so he takes his house into space
meets an alien there
he and the alien become like best
friends he brings the alien back
and they like hang out on Halloween and
then everybody loves everybody like
wants to come hang out with a vampire in
the alien I'm like
dude this was such a like
for a six-year-old like that is a really
fun plot for like a little short book
so good
but he has since wrote way more about
those characters and he's got all sorts
of other fun characters too
best time to go is late winter because
it's calm yeah yeah
Frank thanks for stopping by and hanging
out Frank have a good one
uh Timothy the ninja don't worry my
friend don't worry there will be a
Ravenclaw companion
there will be
a Ravenclaw companion
just a matter of when not a matter of if
it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen
the owl test is fifth year so having to
no longer be home schooled at that point
would make sense
yeah I'm wondering how they're going to
handle that if they're gonna have those
in the game
you got pictures of all the props and
sets at the tour that's awesome
yeah whatever that thing was that I went
on they didn't they allowed no photos
fire burn I was thinking that yesterday
about the start of our arrival to
Hogwarts how do we end up in that
carriage
James has a good video expect to go has
a good video on this I think it's an
older video though
and
I think he's spot on with his timeline I
was thinking about it too even before he
posted that video if you look at kind of
like the clothes that our character is
wearing
I think the timeline goes
something happens with our character
where fig has to go and pick us up
then we go to Gringotts
with fig we run into ran Rock there
then
we're on the carriage heading to
Hogwarts
in the flying Carriage with a fig and
that other guy that's when that guy
shows them the newspaper with ran Rock
talking about the rebellion and it has
the September 1st date on it September
1st 1890 so you know that that day I
mean that's when the Hogwarts Express
that's when they start school
so they're on their way to Hogwarts
right then and there and then that scene
of the little carriage Landing in the
little Courtyard there
that's that's right they're about to go
right into Hogwarts
YouTube put an ad where chat should be
now it's a lot lower than the Stream
like a pop-up ad or something
that's weird
normally during live streams it only
shows ads if I actually manually
trigger them which I did not so I don't
know what that's about Timothy sorry
about that yeah
dude sithray what is up you live in
Orlando and go all the time okay I'm
jealous I'm not gonna lie I'm jealous
diagonal is my favorite place to relax
and enjoy the Wizarding World so would
you say Diagon Alley like is it is it
more fun than uh
than the other side because I've only
been to the hogsmead area that's all
I've been to
a Maury poet haven't been in about 20
years
not sure when you'll get the chance to
go back well if you ever do as a Harry
Potter fan it is absolutely worth it
it is absolutely worth it there's been a
lot of things like
since the original series honestly that
I've been disappointed with in terms of
how
not even not the fandom but just
they could have done so much more like
the Fantastic Beast stuff has been a bit
of a disappointment
even the movie I don't want to upset
anybody but even the movies to an extent
the movies were very good don't get me
wrong but I still don't think they lived
up to what the book and they they messed
up a lot near the end I'm sorry they
just did
but uh you know fine I under I
appreciate the movies for what they did
they they made it even more mainstream
than it already was but the cursed child
stuff as a play I've heard cursed child
is actually very good but the whole the
whole Fiasco with cursed child and in
the Fantastic Beast there's been a lot
of struggles
post launch of the seventh book however
the one thing that they absolutely
crushed and knocked out of the park oh
my gosh see what I did there
pun not intended by the way but but it's
the theme park the theme park they
nailed it they absolutely nailed it it's
incredible it it really is incredible
so for any of you it's it's expensive
not gonna lie it is not cheap it's not
cheap and honestly to get the best bang
for ebook you want to try and stay on
site at one of the Universal Hotels
because then you get to skip the line so
you get in like an hour early
so it's it's definitely worth that too
if you can afford it
but yeah I mean like I said it's not
cheap but I I highly recommend it and I
haven't even been to the other part so
there's a whole other section that I
haven't even seen But even aside from
the Harry Potter stuff like my family
loved going to Universal we went to
Universal for years when we were kids we
did Disney one year and we did Universal
and then we we started going to
Universal because we had just more fun
there
it's kind of funny Universal has Marvel
Superhero Island
they had that before Disney
bought Marvel
so it's kind of weird now that all the
Marvel stuff is not with Disney
as far as I know the last I checked
there was something in the contract
where I don't think Universal can add
any Marvel things I don't think they can
add any new Marvel stuff however they
get to keep
from what I remember I think they can
keep it as long as they want as long as
they don't change anything or add
anything new they get to keep those
rights and oh let me tell you they are
some good rides The Incredible Hulk
coaster and the Spider-Man ride
Incredible
incredible the Spider-Man ride is
probably starting to get a little bit
dated now but when it like the first few
years that it came out man the
technology in that ride were
just incredible
incredible technology when it first came
out okay sorry you guys got me like I
get excited talking about the theme park
stuff and I'm whoever was making fun of
me for being so far behind I know I'm
now even more behind
so I'm gonna have to scroll through I'm
gonna miss a lot of these my apologies
my apologies
I'm gonna have to miss a lot of these
comments
oh you all think that sounded like a fun
book for my my son I know right
right
and he loves sports too like he does
he goes from Sports to reading to video
games I'm like dude yes do it all man do
it all don't get pigeonholed into one
one stereotype you know you don't have
to be just and that was me that was me
in school man I never like in high
school I feel like that's really when
all the clicks start to form right
like the classic the Nerds and the jocks
and the Goths I just like I refuse I I
talk to everybody I I hung out with
everybody I and I was also I was at a
very small school so it was a little bit
easier to do
but yeah like I was I was on an academic
team but I did sports stuff too
I went to dances I went to sporting
events I I you know I did all the things
Ravenclaw Terrell definitely did not
expect it to be as amazing as it was
right I mean it's it's really nice
really nice
careless dreamer never been to any of
the parks but would love to go to Harry
Potter world it's good it's good
hey everyone here wants poppy to go full
Palpatine
I know kids like their minds they just
and I wouldn't encourage him to keep
going with it too we read some of Dave
Pilkey's stuff who
uh Dave does like the Captain Underpants
and there's a thing like about me where
he wrote
he came up with the character for
Captain Underpants when he was in
something like the second or third grade
and I could tell right away that my my
son just like that immediately he's like
wait
I you know it can this is not just uh
this is something I can actually do and
so that's what I was trying to really
get him to understand you know like
because it's one thing for the proud
parent like oh you know my son I love
his writing he does such a good job
but I really think he does I don't think
he does
don't want to take tests do enough of
that in real life I know right
figs like Hagrid I think
I think the Game Keeper is going to be
a lot of people are thinking the name
could be Ernesto Jag but I think it's
the guy that we see with Sebastian and
we see in the trailer with Sebastian and
his sister
I think that's the gamekeeper but fig
could be too although I still think
ancient runes is the most likely for fig
not necessarily owls might not even be a
thing yet true true like we don't know
when they really started
we don't know when they start exactly
seeing ads above the chat that's so
weird that it's above the chat
I mean I could change the position of
chat not tonight but like I could change
where it so is it just on like the lower
right of the screen is that where they
appear like if I had if I had an exact
it's like let's say we moved all of this
down here if we move that to the
complete other side
so like
over you see my mouse if we moved it
over there
would they show up there dude what if
what if YouTube like changed and it
started showing up over the chat over
there
that's crazy
it's left over from the initial ad it's
stuck on that side what in the world
I have played Knights of the Old
Republic yeah one of my favorite games
ever actually
haven't played the second one though
personally uh Travis has diagonally felt
a little small
all the same stuff in the sores oh it's
kind of the same stuff in the shops and
things
living in England haven't had the chance
to go yet still want to see a full-on
series
for you talking about for Harry Potter
Philip like remaking the originals
movies by themselves were good compared
to the books I know right that's where
I'm at
haven't been to Universal in over 15
years yeah it's getting close to that
for me
first fantastic Beast was great second
was pretty good
haven't read cursed child from what I've
heard it doesn't sound great
Ravenclaw Tyrell hey don't be ashamed of
that yeah I mean a lot of people
discovered them through the movies and I
don't want to trash the movies because I
realize they
like I said they took it to a level of
mainstream that the books alone would
have probably never done
that's just the reality
and for a lot of people
they got them into the series so don't
don't be ashamed of that
don't be ashamed saw the movies first
and the books really answer my questions
gonna read the book again before
Hogwarts Legacy
would you'd go if it wasn't in Florida
hate the weather oh the weather's great
if you go in like the off season so like
if you went
and probably like November December uh
January you can get some really nice
weather
so my other favorite rides there I love
The Mummy ride
I love uh
like I said the Hulk coaster is awesome
the Spider-Man ride is awesome there's a
whole like water area too
where it's like um
no we don't want to watch this one we
want more ASMR let's do the other ASMR
a rainy spring night
the the fullest fall ASMR they really
could drop that one at any time between
now and
I you know what
I feel like it has to come before
I guess I could do mid-november but
they definitely will not I mean once you
get into December we're winter so
if you're interested in book suggestions
your eldest maybe he'd like the secrets
of drone
it's one of my favorites when I was
around his age oh I'll look into that
Neil thank you
yeah so so far what all have I read with
him I don't want to bore you guys with
all of it but we've read
we've read Spiderwick
we've read all the Magic Tree House he
just started heroes in training we tried
Narnia
we read line the witch in The Wardrobe
and he liked it but I man I forgot C.S
Lewis is so
like that's a kid's book but man there
are some big words in there
and it's very it's I don't know it's an
interesting Pace he enjoyed it but we I
just thought I probably should have
waited till he was a little bit older on
that one
uh what was there was another one
we read The Hobbit and while that one
does have some big words he really liked
The Hobbit
I want to get him that old animated
movie but I don't even know if he would
sit through it because the animation
compared to uh today's standards he
might be like what is this I can't even
see what these characters are
secrets of drone I'll have to remember
that
I'm gonna put that down in my notes
right now
yeah I work at a library so
I always have a easy access to people
who um
can give me good recommendations
that's how I found out about the heroes
in training
secrets of droon
mommy's your favorite ride by far yeah
mummy's pretty awesome
right I wrote the uh oh my gosh what is
the name of the big Popeye and Pluto's
bilge rat barges
you get soaked on that ride you get
soaked Dudley do-rights ripsaw Falls
oh in the Jurassic Park oh my gosh
the Jurassic Park ride I love that ride
I mean it's so simple but it's just so
they really do a good job of making you
feel like
oh man you're in the park and then you
were now entering the Raptor containment
area
stay calm
and then the end oh it's got one of the
best endings of of any ride
and then there was one more men in
Black's pretty fun I enjoy Men In Black
I don't even know if they still have
that anymore and then there's also like
a super
what is the really fast
but really short roller coaster on the
universal side
there's a roller coaster over there
you guys will probably know the name of
it
and then I used to go back when they
still had the dueling Dragon roller
coasters as well which those were really
fun too
which I don't think I think those are
gone I don't think you can ride those
anymore
I don't think those are anywhere
got Kotor on sale on Xbox for like five
dollars in May it is so good
it is really good I played that game in
college on my
College PC because I didn't I didn't
have an Xbox my PC was not like a gaming
PC at all but it ran it ran it well
enough
Dustin I was the class clown never had
many friends and and even then don't
have any from school days can't remember
getting bullied though but I could have
blocked that from memory I had a great
High School experience college
most people have a bad High School
experience and a good college experience
mine was kind of the opposite but
College wasn't bad it's just
it's kind of weird though I really
didn't I have a couple of people that I
I feel like I'm still close to but we
rarely ever talk it's kind of sad
honestly kind of sad
but I did meet my wife in high school we
didn't go to the same high school but I
met my wife in high school
but yeah now I'd like
man I'm trying to think
I just like once you start having kids
and having a family everything's just
different like time and how you can
spend your time and when you're gonna
hang out with people
midnight release book parties oh my gosh
Owen I miss them
I miss them
I really do I miss them so much
high school students can be mean for
sure yeah
yep for sure
careless dreamer kids made fun of me
because my name is spelled weird oh my
gosh
oh now you guys are gonna scare me like
as my
all you guys are talking about on the
YouTube comments not my actual on-screen
comments
what browser am I using are you talking
to the chat Ravenclaw
I'm using um Chrome is what I'm using
yeah you are throwing me off I thought
you meant like the comments right here
okay you guys are talking about browser
stuff now
or you were like 10 15 minutes ago
oh geez
uh Glenn why haven't any of you
YouTubers asked the question
uh oh everybody's asked Glenn where have
you been
Where Have You Been Glenn literally
that's the question on everybody's mind
all the comments on Twitter that's what
everybody wants to know
I have heard Glenn there's definitely a
Ravenclaw companion it's just a matter
of win
just a matter of when
currently looking for a job have to look
into getting them soon if I can
love nights at the Old Republic second
game is just as good as the first if you
use mods
is Professor fig oh my gosh what if it
was Professor fake
sending hugs wait what are we sending
hugs for I missed I missed something
oh careless dreamer got called a certain
r word oh that's unfortunate
yeah dude kids can be mean and it starts
so early
gosh it starts so early
I'm like
my son I really try
I want to make sure it's gonna sound
like
the the annoying parent well no I don't
think it'll sound like an annoying
parent but you know how parents are
always like I want I want my kid to talk
to me
so I think we have that relationship now
I could always tell when something's
bothering him so but so far he hasn't
had any major major issues there was one
time where some kids were like making
fun of him for not catching a ball
playing uh they were playing football on
the playground but that's really been
the extent of it but like I mean I'm I'm
fully expecting it you know at some
point
unfortunately
like Narnia had trouble keeping up with
it a little bit too complex yeah it is
pretty complex
even even line the witch in The Wardrobe
which is probably the best
starting point
hugs for Maury poet indeed
yeah sorry about sorry to hear that
Maury poet
that was why man I mean I'm sure I upset
some people in college but I I mean in
in high school I don't want to sound
like I was perfect but I re I really did
try
to go out of my way to just not
like not ignore certain people you know
and just include people
so I I hope I was able to I feel like I
was a lot of people still come up to me
like at our reunion and at our senior
trip that year I had a lot of people
come up to me and say
you know say very nice things so
didn't do a couple of you didn't do uni
somebody said a freight was afraid to go
to college Freddie were fail wasn't
smart enough oh come on careless Dreamer
honestly like this day and age it's kind
of crazy what college is
ah
I don't know I I hesitate I don't want
to say something like super
controversial but I feel like I
definitely feel like the importance of
college is significantly lessened that's
probably not too controversial right
like
now you can get
you can learn so much
I don't want to talk up just YouTube
it's not just YouTube but just like the
internet in general like you can learn
so much
and our education system I mean the way
it all
but I don't I don't know that I have
like a great solution like a great
alternative to it
and there I do think there are certain
social skills that you build in college
that are important to have
even other than just the classes
themselves
but you do learn like for a lot of us in
America I don't know how it is in other
countries but like for a lot of us in
America that's our first time on our own
first time with responsibilities on our
own most of us are usually living with
someone else other than family for the
first time so you have to learn about
like responsibilities you know and
keeping your keeping areas clean and
cohabitating with like living in the
same building with a lot of other people
so cleaning up after yourself a lot of
those skills you know they're important
too it's not just about the class but
then also that responsibility of
making sure you get to your classes but
like in terms of the actual like
material that you learn
I feel like so many of us just go to
college and end up not using any of that
or like my degrees are in communication
which is it's so broad like that applies
to just about anything you know
but it's almost to the point where I
feel like unless you're going to college
for a very specific like doctor
nurse attorney engineer you know those
things that have like a very specific
path
it's like you're better off just like
trying to get business experience
I feel like like what I'm doing now
I do work in marketing and my my job was
in or my uh my degrees are in
communication so there is a connection
there
but again that one's so broad that I
could apply that to a lot of different
areas so
hey I don't blame you for that Dustin
getting into debt yep that's a big
reason to not go geeky nerds coming in
with the ten dollar Super Chat and I do
not see a question with it so I geeky
nerds if you meant to have a question
feel free to post it in the comments
I'll try and get to it but if you were
just showing some love to the stream
thank you very much it's very kind of
you I don't think I've seen your name
here before so appreciate you hanging
out with us tonight and choosing to
support with a monetary donation that
means a lot
the lines to get your copy at Barnes
Noble were epic indeed
uh I'm trying to let me think I'm trying
to think of all the places that I went
one year
book five I was at Walmart for midnight
launch
book four I had pre-ordered from I think
Amazon
I think it was Amazon
and it got to my house on launch day
right before we went on a vacation oh my
gosh it was perfect
that's all I did in the whole I know
some people get carsick when they try to
read in the car thankfully I'm not one
of those people my wife is
she cannot like even if she's reading on
her phone for too long
she starts getting sick dude that whole
way down to the beach on our Drive
I was just reading Goblet of Fire
okay so then book six I went to
oh my gosh it was either a borders a
Barnes and Noble or a books a million
you guys remember Books A Million
I want to say it was a borders but it
could have very well been a Barnes and
Noble as well
that was awesome they had like the zoo
there and so they had all these animals
there
and I was on dude I'm always on
vacations for the Harry Potter releases
and then book seven
well I think book Seven was I'm pretty
sure book Seven was a Walmart again
it's 4am for Dr sherbet oh my gosh trade
schools definitely way the way to go get
more investment make the most prepared
employees
they haven't always been popular right
there are some predatory ones as well
get all the books at Walmart careless
Dreamer
also depends on the trades exactly
like now though there is so much you can
do on the internet like if you're
somebody and the other problem is like
you're so you're still so young
You Feel So Young you just don't know
you're expected to know everything
you have people like my wife who just
like the day she
before she graduated high school she
knew she wanted to be a nurse that's
exactly what she did she immediately she
did like a her nurse Tech like
internship thing at the hospital where
she wanted to be not in the exact area
where she wanted to be but she used that
to get a job in the exact
her dream job
and she's been there the whole time
we've been married and she loves it
though I feel like those people are rare
I I was the opposite
I was the opposite
I was pushed in some directions by my
parents I shouldn't say push I was
encouraged like they my parents were
very good very supportive but they they
kind of thought this is the direction
you should go and then
you know I thought about doctor I
thought about Optometry I thought about
um
oh gosh what else did I think of there
were several things that I considered
and then it wasn't until I took a public
speaking class I was like oh my gosh I
love this the broadcasting all of this
um and I always loved like like speaking
and connecting with people so I was like
okay this can work this is pretty broad
I know it's sort of a more generic one
yeah you kind of use it with any it's
harder to get a direct job related to
this
but I just went that path
but if I was somebody like like having
like all like think about just YouTube
in general you could use YouTube to
build a whole business
forget like an MBA man
just take a bunch of YouTube uh courses
right you can get so much info
but also a lot of that's that's the
difficult part about if you just go the
online route or something for that type
of education it's just like a
free-for-all you know
at least with a formal education through
a university there are at least some
standards
some standards that they have to have in
place but it's also incredibly expensive
as somebody was talking about with the
the debt issue Dr sherbet gotta head out
before you pass out all good yo Chris
Chris got a birthday
let's go happy Birthday Chris
also got yours from borders uh able
Knight Road able Knight Rd nice
yeah borders were awesome
I don't know if they still have any
borders anymore I think they do
I think it was books a million those are
definitely gone Walden books you guys
remember Walden books
yeah high IQ there you go engineer
that's a good example like that's one
where
that's a very good example of how you
definitely need the schooling for it and
you pretty much instantly use it
all right
let's see what time is it yeah I gotta
hop off pretty soon okay here's here's a
fun story I'll leave you guys with we've
had a lot of fun talking about
book launches and all that
so I was so terrified of spoilers for
book seven so terrified
I don't know if you guys remember
one of the most popular it's probably
still on YouTube to this day there was a
video when book six came out
of someone driving in front of a
bookstore
sticking their head out of a window I'm
gonna spoil book six by the way
spoiling Harry Potter
Half Blood Prince if you haven't read it
turn off the stream now
somebody drives by a bookstore
stickster head out the window and yells
Snape kills Dumbledore
and these two I think it was two girls
walking by and they're just like
their face just felt they were like what
and that
haunted me
I had devoted years of my life to this
series I was not going to be spoiled by
it so
my wife and I were sitting there in the
Walmart we weren't we weren't husband
and wife at the time so she was my
girlfriend at the time we were in line
waiting at the Walmart for book seven
and it's like 10 minutes to midnight
they're they're Wheeling the books out
and all of a sudden I just have this
horrible realization
I just have this horrible not
realization this horrible fear
it's like dude what if there's some punk
in here who immediately
tries to flip to the last page and spoil
somebody
don't ask me why it crossed my mind but
it did
and so I'm like I I jump up and I'm like
scrambling I I tell my wife I'm like
again girlfriend at the time I'm like
here
's my card pay for it I gotta go to the
car she's like what are you what is
wrong with you what are you doing
what are you doing
and I'm like I'm afraid somebody's gonna
spoil this I have to go I can't I can't
I do not want to have this bullet I've
waited years and so I just take I just
leave I just take off go to the car and
wait
and she's just standing there like what
and there were some people that we had
kind of been talking to and uh sort of
became friends with them while we're
waiting in line and she said after I
left they're like where is he going
and I just I couldn't I the fear of it
man I I had spent so many years wait I
can't even describe though some of you
are probably old enough here in the chat
to know if you were fans from the
beginning
we had been waiting like if you were
fans from before the movies from like
this was years in the making
years in the making so many Message
Board posts and theories and podcasts
that I listen to Breaking this down
guessing and predicting what was gonna
happen
I could not be spoiled
could not be spoiled
so I had to just go I had to get out of
there had to go to the car
and that's what I did to keep her being
spoiled
that video's still there hey it doesn't
surprise me I bet it has millions and
millions and millions of views too
Timothy Ninja's got a mass Explorer for
no way home on my YouTube homepage
hey that's something we need to talk
about at some point that's something we
need to talk about
because I want I want to figure out
what's the best way for me to handle
spoilers on Hogwarts Legacy after it
comes out
because you're exactly that's such a
good point Timothy like
and I mean I'm not going to tell you
guys don't don't go on YouTube
but where you all are big supporters of
the channel if you go on YouTube You're
Gonna Get suggested my video and if you
haven't
gotten like and I'm gonna be very
careful with story spoilers obviously
Philip thanks so much for hanging out
have a good night
good to see you congrats on that uh
gifted membership as well
I'll be incredibly careful with story
spoilers obviously but what if there's
like some
like I'm like 10 10 collectibles in the
Gryffindor common room you know
I'll just have to be very careful I
guess with the titles and thumbnails
I never got to appreciate any of the
twists watch them all the movies really
young oh gotcha
yeah I mean as a kid I'm sure adults
reading sorcerer slash philosopher stone
I'm sure it wasn't a surprise when you
got to the end and it was quarrel and
not
Snape but for my sixth sixth grade
mind seventh grade
maybe in between six and seven no I
think it was seventh grade I think it
was seventh grade
I was just my jaw was on the floor I was
like
it's squirrel are you kidding me
are you kidding me
zodiac don't spoil on thumbnail title
yeah yeah for sure
but I'm just trying to think there might
even be things like
like what if there's an item that we
don't know what's in the game
and then we find out it's in so like
Deathly Hallows for example what if you
find out the Deathly Hallows are in the
game
I would make a video on that how to get
the Deathly Hallows in Hogwarts Legacy
it's like that's a spoiler right there
but I'm like how could you title that
video
it would just seem like super click bait
if I'm like get this super rare item no
one expected
oh well we'll cross that bridge when we
get to it
that's a good problem to have good
problems I have but yeah story spoilers
I think will be pretty easy to avoid
it's it's like the item thing and maybe
the even locations enemies those types
of things bosses I mean are we gonna
have bosses I don't know
I don't know
geeky nerds with another Super Chat and
yet another one with no question you
guys just showing Crazy Love support for
the stream tonight
thank you so much geeky nerds very much
appreciated thank you for hanging out
and choosing to support the Stream
oh my gosh Nico if you can would you
mind posting the Discord link real quick
again I want to set up that
chat command really quick
I had it pulled up and then went off on
my tangent completely forgot about it so
oh yeah Nat Knight I agree with you yeah
like the day the day it comes out I'm
like deathly yeah
you guys would be like unsub unsub I
wouldn't blame you no I'll be very
careful about that stuff for sure
but then it's like there is like a time
time limit to it right like what is a
fair amount of time
thanks Nico I got it all right let's see
uh
join Retros Discord
here
all right activate command
now let's test the command because it is
kind of Hit or Miss
with stream elements exclamation point
Discord
come on
come on you could do it
come on
well I wonder if it's like the 60 second
thing wonder if it waits 60 Seconds
I do not understand you sometimes stream
elements
I do not understand you
there is a global cool down a user cool
down
why wouldn't that work I'll have to look
into it later
standard for game spoilers on most games
seems to be about two weeks that's fair
that's fair
really gonna go hard those three days
before release from the pre-order and
come back to the internet on Sunday
probably 60 hours in you could do a
title like huge secret gameplay feature
in Hogwarts Legacy make it super quick
baby right oh there it was so it worked
okay it just took a little bit
just took a little bit for stream
elements wait it worked for Nat night
but not for me
come on man
come on
we should get a release date for switch
I'm worried about the switch I am I'm
really worried about it
I gotta lie to you guys
not gonna lie
comments are really slow today what
gives with that a type so fast the
weight is painful
I am so sorry I'm Maury poet it is uh I
put a uh cool down on it
geeky nerds with another Super Chat a 10
dollars Super Chat geeky nerds thank you
so much what if we are a child born from
ancient magic much like Anakin from
midichlorians
dude what if Hogwarts Legacy introduces
us to The Wizarding World version of
midichlorians
no please please though
don't go there please
I I mean
uh it could be though the whole ancient
magic thing it could be like a child of
ancient magic I'd much rather just be
like a descendant of Merlin or something
though
much rather much rather be a cinema
geeky nurse thank you so much again for
your support of the stream and that
Super Chat there
considering how surprisingly well the No
Man's Sky switch Port runs not super
worried I mean hopefully they can pull
it off I hope so they they did it was
developed on last gen
so
oh is that a cloud version is no man's
Sky a cloud version uh interesting
interesting
still want to find out why are we
consider something of a celebrity right
Jay Rossi exactly what did we survive
what did we survive
oh Mary you're you're playing on switch
someone only able to play this game on
switch I'm going to continue Mary let me
ask you this do you hope for it to be
a cloud version or not a cloud version
because there are pros and cons to it we
don't know yet Arcane we don't know yet
for sure
so if it is a cloud version here here
are the advantages the advantages are
you do not have to worry about the
graphical fidelity you do not have to
worry about frame rate it's going to
look and run great because it's running
on a super powered PC somewhere it's not
running natively on your system
the downside is you have to be connected
to the internet you have to have a good
internet connection it kills any
possibility of you playing it on the
road unless you're doing like you know
uh service on your phone or something
and
what else there are other disadvantages
too
buffering you know all those sorts of
things
and
I I think I used to think it was most
likely a cloud version but now I think
it's physical I think it's physical
because I don't think they would do
we've seen the game box we've seen the
deluxe edition
and switch is included in the deluxe
edition
I feel like they would have I would hope
they would have said something by now
if they're just shipping a game box with
a digital code in it
I would hope
cooldown is there for members as well
nah no cooldown for us I think it's
there I think it's Universal
yeah chat's on slow mode so Mary's
probably trying to write back right now
because it takes 60 Seconds
dude that would be a nice perk though
for members
I wonder if there's a way you can set it
to where members don't have a slow mode
I'll have to look into that
and honestly like it's it's not like
done to it's purely done as a reason to
help me keep up with chat I mean like
you guys see how crazy it was tonight
and that's with the 60 second cooldown
but thank you for the videos Hey Stephen
thank you my friend thank you for
supporting the videos and checking out
the channel
hope you have a good night at work
thanks for stopping by
no no no
oh I feel bad now I could turn it off I
mean we could turn it off next time I do
not want anybody to try and pay to get
rid of it
I know James expecto Goes been
experimenting with it some as well
because
I mean it's it's a compliment to you
guys really it's a compliment
for how fast the chat is flowing
but the conversations that we like to
have based on just like two three little
comments they can go in so many
different directions that I mean I just
get so far behind I get so far behind
even without slow mode on and then or
excuse me even with slow mode on I get
so far behind
have a good one careless dreamer have a
good one dude Jake just back to back
right there
what wait so Jake not affected by the
cooldown
maybe members aren't affected
somebody said members were affected
oh wait they just
they just all went away
[Music]
oh I bet Jake got in trouble for I bet
steam uh stream elements Got Jake for
spamming
oh that's funny
no Amore poet don't do it don't do it
save your money I'll turn it off next
stream I do not want you to spend money
just for that
do not want you to spend money just for
that I don't even know if that works for
sure so
it shows slow mode when you're typing
high IQ Warriors but not sure yeah
that's really weird
doesn't affect much
I mean clearly Jake either found a way
around it but now
Jake might have gotten timed out
for spamming all of that
what's up Tom beyond ready for this game
so excited
Tyrell has two IT jobs wait what did
Ravenclaw Tyrell say yes I am too all
right Jake
haven't had one password call at work
this entire stream
oh you work in it gotcha I thought
you're talking about the program one
password I was like what is one password
I mean I know what one password is I was
like what are you talking about one
password for on my chat window there's a
circle around the arrow that sends your
message and until that Circle completes
it goes away I cannot send another
message yeah I think that's what's
supposed to work for everybody I have it
set to a 60 second cooldown tonight so
after you send one
comment it's supposed to make everybody
wait a full 60 seconds before you can
comment again
that was that was on my end Amory poet I
can set that up and I could lower it too
like we could try 30 seconds or we could
we could try to go back to disabling it
I definitely I and I I do not know if it
gets rid of it for becoming a member
ah Noob says I don't get that
interesting
Amore has a setup where they can't
receive gifts oh what
getting the new house the new house
robes wait what are you talking about
what house robes
Mary I'll just say what I said before oh
yeah I did miss it I I thought I was
waiting for it I never saw it I prefer
physical gotcha okay rather than a cloud
version
Circle appears for 60 seconds you can
type but not send uh okay yeah Ravenclaw
Tyrell don't get it been double chatting
all night
oh the ones for linking your account
zodiac I think that's what they're
talking about
oh yeah Maury poet you have what it's
like a business account or something
or a brand account that's it
dude that's good to know though Noob
that's good to know well no wonder chat
was still flying Fast and Furious
everybody here was member most everybody
here was already a member
so the slow mode is doing absolutely
nothing
oh my gosh hey good problem to have dude
I'm not complaining I remember the days
of I stream on Twitch to two and three
people like begging for begging for a
comment
like I need another comment
I need a comment just no cut no chat
going on at all
slow mode is pain okay so for all the
non
now it makes sense now it makes sense
why the people I can see
all the green ones in chat
are all members so they're just like
chatting freely everybody else like what
the heck is going on
lower classic slow
I promise I did not know that I did not
know that
I wish I could untie my Jake wouldn't
have done
so Nico did it Nico timed out Jake for
five minutes oh my gosh that's too funny
that's too funny Jake's like look I
could type however much I want Nico's
like
I have the power of the mod sword
denied pay to win oh my gosh you guys
are gonna start that retro has pay to
win mechanics on his live streams I knew
he sold he sold out first to Harry
Potter Hogwarts mystery
uh sponsored uh video
now he's making his YouTube live streams
pay to win
I really did not know that that's
interesting though that that members get
to bypass that so that's I should put
that on the benefits page though
that you're not you're not subject to
to the uh slow mode
and Elwood Elwood oh my gosh Elwyn
showing Mercy on Owen's like okay look
for those of you I'm gonna gift five
more here
so some of you who want to chat freely
will be able to do so L when gifting 5
more memberships that's 10 on the night
just from Elwyn
elwin thank you so much
[Music]
and a lot of new names look at this a
lot of names that I haven't seen in the
chat tonight so congrats to those of you
who just got a gift of membership from
Elwyn make sure you give Elwood a thank
you Elwood is an incredible supporter of
the stream always in here showing love
Reese you're still live we are still
live
Jake with the with the Super Chat I got
in trouble by Nico
how are you welcome to Gryffindor oh my
gosh
that did feel like five more didn't it
the little pop-up just said five
whatever it was thank you so much Owen
no option on phone uh that's right yeah
everybody always asks on phone
all right guys
this has been crazy I appreciate the
love
appreciate the support geeky nerds long
time Watcher new to the chat yo geeky
nerds
thanks for all your support of the
channel
and I appreciate those uh super chats
tonight look still not a member because
I get no gifts retro if you like making
a new mod
ah what a would mod get that would be a
way to get around that hmm okay okay
okay
Noob you know what probably next I mean
next Tuesday that's kind of uh wait that
was 10.
oh my gosh Elwyn
why does it only show five
elwin thank you so much
tan did we just get 10 gifteds from
Elwyn
wow or did I admit did somebody else
gift five more I want to make sure I
didn't miss somebody else who gifted
five more
I think I don't think we missed anyone
because it didn't show up in my little
pop-up there
it did not show up in my pop-up
you know what I'm worry poet we might
just experiment next time without doing
the uh we might turn off slow mode see
how it goes
see how it goes with no slow mode I mean
that's how we used to do it we used to
do no slow mode
but then the chat just got
pretty fast
showing only five okay okay gotcha
gotcha
it was five all right yeah
I don't know why I kept seeing seeing
people say 10. all right look I could I
could do this all night I really could I
gotta hop off I gotta work in the
morning uh I hope you all have a
fantastic rest of your evening thank you
all for hanging out uh we've got
possibly two more videos hitting the
channel this week if you haven't watched
today's video yet go check it out
um it's a recap of all the latest all
the latest news Amore poet
and what else what else what else
definitely one more video this week but
possibly two and then next live stream
most likely on Tuesday
but um I want to do more gaming live
streams too guys so keep an eye out for
those as well those will be spur of the
moment but I definitely wanna
I think it's a lot better when I can
schedule them
it's like if I could if I could schedule
him even just like a day in advance I
think that'd give a lot more of you a
chance to be there and and hang out so
but right now man right now my time is
still only in the evening unfortunately
if I'm ever in a position
where
I mean you guys know I've said it before
I want to do this full time like this
this is what I want to do
and I think we can get there I really do
um
I really do I think we can get there and
if that ever is to happen to where this
becomes my full-time thing then I mean
we'll be doing streams all the time
be doing multiple streams in the week uh
during the day so we wouldn't have to
stick just to these late night hours so
one day one day I don't know when don't
know how soon it will be
but one day
so uh
thank you everybody
who's been here hanging out hope you all
have a fantastic rest of your evening
rest of your week
and uh I'll talk to you again soon yeah
sorry about that Jake sorry about that
I mean hey Nico
it's lucky you're lucky it wasn't a band
right
lucky Nico didn't didn't bring down the
band hammer
thank you all have a good one
foreign